Das war's für heute.
Ich wünsche euch einen guten Abend.
Schauen wir nochmal!
So bin ich, ich mach jetzt mal heute Abend wieder ein bisschen Stream an, auch wenn
es nix groß, doch es gibt was, ich hab sogar was vor.
Wir suchen später noch mal ein paar Stellenanzeigen raus für Stellenanzeigen Review Teil 2.
Deswegen zeige ich den Desktop auch immer, weil ich weiß genau der Chat der freut sich
jedes Mal wenn sie meinen Desktop sehen.
Habt ihr gesehen Leute es gibt neue Emotes, wir haben neue Emotes, guckt mal, passt auf,
wir haben, guckt mal hier, wir haben Wub, Moment, wir haben Wub, Gazm haben wir jetzt, Wub
Kobold gibt es vielleicht auch noch ja, dann haben wir neu, Wub, Old, der finde ich cool
irgendwie, Wub, Old und der beste neue finde ich, Wub, Pock, der ist nice oder, Wub, Pock,
Passive.
Achso, wir haben glaube ich, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, wir haben noch 20 Emote Slots Leute,
ich muss noch 20 Emote, was soll ich denn alles machen ey, wobei ich machs ja eh nicht.
Wub, Pock, Wub, Rubiknob, Pfeif, Wub, Pfeifett machen wir vielleicht noch, Wub, Wub, Pfeifett
machen wir noch, ich brauch erstmal paar Ideen, wir brauchen Ideen für die Emotes, dass wir
die Designerin von Patrick da beauftragen können, die Emotes zu machen, der Sebaro
ist auch am Start, ich wusste, dass dem Sebaro dieses Emote gefällt, man muss ja sagen, das
sieht jetzt, das sieht eher nach weiblichem Keks aus, auch ein bisschen mit den Wimpern
und so, aber warum nicht.
Wub, Eier, Eier, das machen wir auch noch, Wub, Eier, Eier gibt es noch, das ist schon
on the way.
Siehste, jetzt haben sich jetzt die Leute das schon seit Jahren erzählt und jetzt endlich
wissen wir auch warum.
Watch out Needles, wenn du mich so fragst, solltest du, je nachdem was es ist, Uni Vorbereitung
machen, aber big brain ist, Stream dabei laufen lassen, weil wir wissen ja, dass es durch
jeden Sub mehr IQ gibt, das heißt, wenn du Stream guckst und lernst gleichzeitig, dann
kannst du einfacher lernen.
IQ Boost, soll ich euch mal was erzählen, weil ihr gerade was erzählt von Lernen und
sonst was, ich hab was gemacht, was ich ja sonst nie mache, ich muss mal kurz die Musik
ein Ticken leiser machen, Leute, ich hab was gemacht, was ich sonst nie mache, ich hab
mich freiwillig, kann sein, dass ich das schon mal erzählt hab, ich hab mich freiwillig dafür
gemeldet, was zu arbeiten, auf der Arbeit, also nein, stimmt nicht, was zu machen auf
der Arbeit, ohne dass ich dafür Geld krieg, so und zwar, die haben bei uns so ein komisches
Event am Wochenende, Freitag um Samstag, ja Leute, ich glaub selbst nicht, ich hab selbst
nicht geglaubt, zumindest, also, das ist eine gute Idee, ich glaub, das hab ich mir sogar
aufgeschrieben für eines der nächsten Videos, jetzt ohne Scheiß, übrigens eins hab ich
auf Twitter gelernt die letzten Tage, eins hab ich auf Twitter die letzten Tage gelernt,
man darf alles sagen, solange man nur Kappa hinten dran schreibt, also Chat, ihr ganzen
Kack, Kack, Drecksnoobs, Kappa, Hauptsache Kappa hinten dran schreiben, dann ist alles
gut, so, also was ich euch erzählen wollte ist folgendes, während wir uns hier noch
bisschen die neuen Emotes ausprobieren können, genau, das sind die Typen, das sind die Typen,
die früher immer gesagt haben, so nach dem Motto, alter du Kack Spaß, irgendwie, ich
fick deine Mutter, nur Spaß, nur Spaß, nur Spaß, nur Spaß, wenn die dann gemerkt haben,
vielleicht kriegen sie aus dem Auto, nur Spaß, nur Spaß, und das Gegenteil davon ist im Internet
die Leute, die Kappa dahinter schreiben, always snow in Siberia weiß, um was es geht, ja,
aber da sind die wieder, die Leute auf, aber ganz im Ernst, die sind wieder alle total
ausgerastet, also ich find die ursprüngliche Aktion alles andere als gut, das muss ich
an der Stelle auch noch mal sagen, aber, also, die Ausmaße, die das Ganze wieder angenommen
hat, ist, ich glaub das kriegen wir auch nur im Streamer YouTube Land Deutschland hin, also
da haben's echt wieder voll übertrieben, ich hab gestern beim Lost eingeschaltet, weil
mich interessiert was er dazu gesagt hat, und das war auch alles sehr sinnig, was er
erzählt hat, ich mach den Streamer und auf einmal ist er übelst am ausrasten und flamet
irgendein, hat irgendeiner im Chat geschrieben, so nach dem Motto, bla bla bla, alle ehrenlos,
boah, da ging er ab, Alter, ich kann ihn ja verstehen, ja, ich kann ihn ja verstehen,
aber ich könnt mich da überhaupt nicht so drüber aufregen, er ist übelst eskaliert
im Stream, Alter, naja, aber ich finde, es muss ja jeder mal wieder sein, Senf zu geben,
Leute, die damit nichts zu tun hatten, nichts mitbekommen haben, alle haben sich irgendein
Statement abgelassen auf Twitter, oder am besten noch irgendwie Realtalk, YouTube Video und
so, ich bin ja nur froh, dass mich zu diesem Scheiß mittlerweile keiner mehr fragt, nachdem
ich 6 Jahre auf YouTube nichts gemacht hat, ich kenne keinen mehr, die kennen mich auch
nicht mehr, und deswegen fragt mich zum Glück auch keiner, so, und der Wahnsinn, ey, echt,
wie sie alle abgegangen sind, naja gut, also was ich euch erzählen wollte, das ist nämlich
gar nicht das, was ich euch erzählen wollte, was hast du verpasst, ich will es nicht erzählen,
geh auf YouTube, such Rust Server, Realtalk, was auch immer, da gibt es 1000 Videos zu,
die das erklären, Max, wie alt bist du jetzt eigentlich, ich bin glaube ich 36, oder bin
ich 37, oder bin ich 35, ich glaube ich bin 36, ich bin 1984 geboren, Mitte des Jahres
1984, also bin ich 36, oder, ja, ich glaube schon, ne, aber ohne Scheiß, Leute, ich komme
da wirklich manchmal ein bisschen durcheinander, so, also, keck wait, der Chat backseat sidetrackt
mich schon wieder, also was ich euch eigentlich erzählen wollte, keck wait, ich habe mich
auf der Arbeit freiwillig gemeldet, dass ich am Freitag, am Samstag bei so einem Event
mitmache, die haben jetzt so was, so was Neues gestartet, irgend so ein Innovationswettbewerb
oder sowas, ja, normalerweise, ihr kennt mich, Leute, normalerweise mache ich bei so einem
Scheiß nicht mit, und schon gar nicht, schon gar nicht, weil es keine Arbeitszeit ist,
aber, und das ist der Grund, warum ich mitgemacht habe, ist, die haben gesagt, sie suchen Ideen
für eine Android-App, und nachdem ich so selten selbst noch programmiere auf der Arbeit, habe
ich gesagt, ey, weißt du was, so eine Android-App ist eine coole Sache, ich habe noch nie eine
Android-App gemacht, natürlich machen wir da in den zwei Tagen keine Android-App, sondern
wir machen ein Prototyp, oder, sag mal so, wir machen vielleicht ein paar, so Mock-up-Skits,
vielleicht machen wir auch so einen Mini-Prototyp im Browser, oder so, aber sowas haben die
noch nie gemacht, ja, sowas, nein, nein, nein, nicht Kotlin oder Java, HTML, CSS, Javascript,
Web-App, ich fange noch nicht mit Java an, doch, doch, Aufwachstream gibt es, es ist
nur, es ist, es ist Freitag, Mittag, bis Abends, und dann Samstags, bis Mittag, ist nicht
so lang, ist nicht so lang, und ich wette mit euch, die cheaten alle, die Drecksäcke,
die cheaten, und zwar man konnte sich anmelden, mit Teamgröße 4-5 Leute, und man konnte sich
anmelden, und ich wette mit euch, die Leute, die haben, im Vorfeld, es haben sie irgendwie
5-6 Teams angemeldet, und die haben garantiert schon eine fertige Android-App, die haben
garantiert die letzten zwei Wochen, da wo ich noch im Urlaub war, haben die da gesessen,
haben eine neue Android-App gemacht, mich würd's nicht wundern, wenn da am Freitag die
Leute aufkreuzen und sagen, hier ist der Store-Link, oder irgendwie sowas, aber wir haben das zufälligerweise
schon im Android Store, könnt ihr einfach runterladen und ausprobieren, das würd mich
echt nicht wundern, alles cheater, so, wir halten uns zumindest halbwegs dran, wir haben
außer ein Google-Docs-Dokument mit ein bisschen Ideensammlung noch nix gemacht, und wir machen
das dann alles Freitag, Samstag, so Leute, das heißt, easy win, und genau, was ich euch
dabei erzählen wollte ist folgendes, man musste sich eine Name ausdenken für das Team,
also sprich man konnte sich anmelden mit den Leuten, Name eintragen und Teamname sich
überlegen, und ich hatte richtig gute Ideen, ich hab das ja auch im Discord geschrieben,
also von Team Poggers bis Fiveheads, weil das 5 Leute sind, bis GG Eats, und so richtig
coole Meme-Names für das Team, das Problem war, wir haben da 2 Leute dabei, die mögen
das nicht, die sind glaub ich noch ein bisschen mehr Boomer als ich, keine Ahnung, und der
Felix hätt's lustig gefunden, da bin ich mir sicher, so, und dann hab ich gesagt, ok,
wisst ihr was, wir machen ein Kompromiss, wir machen GLHF als Teamname, goodluck have fun,
das ist eigentlich noch coole Sache, das ist ein bisschen sportlich und ein bisschen Internet-Meme-Gedöns
und so, so, alle wollten sie alle nicht, wollten sie alle nicht, so, wisst ihr wie wir jetzt
heißen, wir haben den, wir haben den, wir haben den, wir haben den Paynes-Champex-Namen
überhaupt, wir heißen jetzt Agile Octopus, Paynes-Champex, der Sebaro hat schon gleich
festgestellt, dass das ja gleich Hentai, dass das was mit Hentai zu tun hat, das hab ich
noch dran erinnert, gleich im Discord geschrieben, gleich, wie die anderen heißen, die anderen
haben noch schlimmere Namen, das eine Team heißt für Ruhm und Ehre, das hört fast schon
irgendwie aus, warum nicht, in einem rechten Forum sein oder so, Alter, für Ruhm und Ehre,
nein nicht für Blut und für Ruhm und Ehre, dann gibt's noch Team-Mehrwert oder sowas,
das sind alles so, so, so, frag mich nicht, Paynes-Champex-Namen, ein bisschen groß die
Modes vielleicht, naja, zumindest so heißen wir jetzt, zumindest werde ich am Freitag
dann anfangen und wir werden unsere Android-App zusammen basteln, zumal wir keine wirkliche
Android-App bauen, wir bauen eine Android-App aus CSS, HTML und JavaScript, letztendlich
ist das die Geschichte, wie heute die meisten Mobile-Apps entstehen, ja, aber richtige Boomer-App,
Massive-Boomer.
Ey, Moment, warum gehe ich jetzt eigentlich auf Amazon, da gibt's überhaupt keinen Sinn,
so, ich mache jetzt erstmal kurz andere Musik, nachdem wir das nochmal durchlaufen lassen
haben, ich weiß nicht, was das ist, da klicke ich jetzt nicht drauf, da klicke ich nicht
drauf, weil man weiß, wo man so eine Uhr rauskommt, gut, ich muss mal kurz hier einstellen, dass
ich highlighted werde, Chat-Highlights, meine Messages an mich müssen geheiligthet werden,
FFZ please, Highlight, äh, wo ist das hin, äh, äh, filtering, achso, Highlight-Matched-Words,
wo trage ich jetzt die Wörter ein, what the fuck, da ist viel drüber, hä, hier ist überhaupt
nichts oben drüber, hier, das ist nicht, nein, Leute, der Chat, der Chat verstehts
wieder nicht, der Chat verstehts wieder nicht, ich bin doch gar nicht eingeloggt, Chat, jetzt,
jetzt, jetzt, jetzt reichts, jetzt reichts, keck wait, ok, also, machen wir das ganze
noch mal, Highlight-Matched-Words, so, wo trage ich Matched-Words ein, Highlight-Users, ah,
Roblox, excellent, ok, mal gucken, ob das jetzt funktioniert, Leute, nein, funktioniert
nicht, geht nicht, hm, geht das nicht, Highlight-Matched-Words, also, Matched-Words gibts ja an sich schonmal
nicht, ach, das ist, ah, Highlight-Terms, ach, ich kack noob, da ist es doch, so, jetzt
aber, ah, wunderbar, exquisite, ne, ne, so passt das, so passt das, so erkenne ich das,
so erkenne ich das, alles klar, wunderbar, Uul ist immer noch safe, klingt es trotzdem
da dann, kennst du Chatterino, ja, kenne ich, so, wunderbar, das weiß ich net, da stehen
die neuen Pocky-Modes, genau, Virgin-Check, Pocky-W, I'm safe, warum kenne ich diese,
warum kenne ich so sinnlose Copypastas eigentlich auswendig, gut, auf gehts, also, ach ja, Chat,
ich wollte euch noch was fragen, jetzt, ernsthaft, also wirklich, kack wait, ich wollte ein Video
machen, ich wollte ein Video machen zu die wichtigsten Skills in der IT, so, man muss
ein bisschen Clickbait-Überschrift machen, ne, und, da wollte ich eigentlich drauf raus,
dass das beste was man, also das wichtigste was man machen, was man wissen muss ist, warte
mal, genau, man muss, man muss suchen können, und man muss wissen nach was man sucht, das
sind eigentlich die zwei wichtigsten Skills, also du musst so viel Ahnung haben, du musst
so viel Ahnung haben, dass du weißt nach was du suchen musst, und dann musst du doch
richtig suchen können, dass das funktioniert, Copypaste, Copypaste ist tatsächlich auch
nicht unwichtig, weil man muss wissen wie und was man Copypastet, habt ihr noch irgendwelche
Ideen, Terminal, ne, das ist zu, zu realistisch, ich mein so bisschen so was abstraktes, so
wie gesagt so was wie suchen können oder so, ne, ein Ausschalten passt auch nicht, ja Google
hab ich ja schon, man muss wissen nach was man sucht, man muss wissen wie man sucht,
man muss die Strucke reparieren, exellent, Spaß haben, wo sind wir denn hier, jetzt wollten
die Leute schon Spaß haben, letztens haben sie sich erst noch darüber gewundert, dass
man für die Abschlussprüfung lernen muss, und jetzt soll das ganze noch Spaß machen,
ich glaub es geht los, gut ich seh der Chat ist heut für nix zu gebrauchen, bring
Raspberry Pi 4 ist kaputt, den ich bestellt hab.
Ich hab mir jetzt doch nur ein 4 GB Modell bestellt bei Amazon, der geht nicht.
Der geht nicht an.
Der smoke nicht mal, der geht einfach nicht an.
Ja, du kannst, du kannst noch nicht mal falsch reinstecken.
Beim alten Raspberry Pi konntest du ja noch einen Strom falsch dranstecken,
aber hier kannst du gar nichts falsch machen.
Ich glaub, das Ding ist einfach im Arsch.
Sieht top in Ordnung aus.
Neu glänzendes Board, alles okay.
Hast du ein richtiges Netzteil?
Ich hab das originale Raspberry Pi Netzteil.
5 Volt, 3, ähm, 5,1 Volt, 3 Ampere oder irgendwie sowas.
Also keine Ahnung, was damit ist.
Wie gesagt, falsch reinstecken kann man nicht, das ist USB-C.
Ich könnte nur noch mal probieren, ob das Netzteil kaputt ist,
indem ich mit dem Netzteil meinen anderen Raspberry Pi...
Aber das glaub ich nicht.
Tu mal die Pins schrotten.
Ja, das klingt natürlich äußerst sinnvoll, Chat.
Genau, das mach ich jetzt.
Und dann gucken, ob's raucht.
Nö.
Übrigens, ich hab's heut auf Twitter geschrieben, ne?
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr, woran man die größten Schleimer auf der Arbeit erkennt?
Ich hab's heut wieder gesehen, ne?
Und zwar ist mir heut wieder aufgefallen und zwar hier dran.
Wir haben so nen Blog, wo die... wo der vorstand,
ich hab so die Geschäftsleitung geschrieben,
aber wo der vorstand stand, ist mir heute aufgefallen,
und zwar hier dran.
Wir haben so einen Blog, wo der vorstand,
Ich hab zwar hier Geschäftsleitung geschrieben, aber wo der Vorstand Schräg-Geschäftsleitung
immer neue, neue Dinger verkündet, da steht dann zum Beispiel so Sachen drin wie
dass sie jetzt einen neuen, frag mich nicht, wir haben einen neuen Einkaufsprozess etabliert, blablabla
Im Prinzip zu 99% Sachen, die mich ehrlich gesagt nicht großartig interessieren
und es gibt aber so ein paar Leute, die hast du immer als erstes in den Likes von diesen Blogposts
immer, es sind immer die gleichen 3-4 Leute und ich wette, man kann da so eine Newsfeed abonnieren
für diesen Blog, hat keiner gemacht, weil da im Prinzip wie gesagt 99% langweilige Sachen drin stehen
aber es sind immer die 3-4 gleichen Leute, die den Kram liken, dass sie oben stehen
das ist so Fail, haben die nichts besseres zu tun als das zu liken, wahrscheinlich kommt das noch nicht mal gut an
wahrscheinlich kommt das nicht mal gut an, wahrscheinlich sind das die ersten, die gekickt werden, weil sie sagen
ey wie kann das sein, hast du nichts besseres zu tun wie morgens um 10 Newsplog zu lesen
es könnte nach hinten losgehen, ja das stimmt
das ist ein RSS Feed glaubt zumindest, weil das ist in diesem Atlassian Zeugs drin
ein bisschen kräubige Dudel, ah yes, excellent
genau übrigens, wir gucken heute mal ein bisschen nach neuen Stellenanzeigen für Stellenangebote Review Teil 2
allerdings diesmal Teamwork, das ist tatsächlich eine gute Idee, ich weiß nicht ob ich das sagen soll
aber die Idee finde ich dann schlecht das nochmal anzuhören
wie läuft der Preistrecker?
Serious Max, ich hab es jetzt so wie du gemacht, ich hab was fertiges genommen, da schreibt ihr Ergebnis in Redis und ich kann das auswerten, aber ich hab das sonst nichts mehr großartig programmiert
mach den LinkedIn Account
was muss man dafür angeben sich bei LinkedIn zu registrieren?
ich war legit, die Musik ist zu laut, ich war legit noch nie bei Xing oder LinkedIn registriert
ich hab da immer einen großen Bohrung drum gemacht, aber Xing ist doch in Deutschland beliebter oder?
damals gab es das noch nicht, so siehts aus
ich seh die Leute bei uns auf der Arbeit die haben alle Xing-Profile, liegt das daran weil die so krasse Boomer sind?
bei uns auf der Arbeit die haben alle Xing-Profile, LinkedIn dachte ich haben die Amis eher
ok wir registrieren uns jetzt mal bei LinkedIn
John Mett das stimmt alles, logisches Denken finde ich gut
ich will so ein bisschen was abstraktes und so Dinge wo man nicht zuerst drauf kommt
kannst du nach Ausbildung stellen? kann ich machen? muss man nur sagen als was?
ok dann machen wir uns jetzt mal ein LinkedIn Account, also wir brauchen erstmal 10 Minute Mail
und dann können wir uns ein paar Fehler eingestehen
da tut sich eigentlich jeder ein bisschen schwer
ich schreib mir das aber auch mal auf
was aber auch ein Problem ist, Chat, vielleicht kennt das der eine oder andere von der Arbeit
da wird immer so getan nach dem Motto, ja wir sind doch alles Menschen, wenn man Fehler ist, kann ja passieren
also wenn ihr mal was falsch macht, so und dann macht mal einer was falsch
was? was ist hier los? wir hatten jetzt 2 Stunden Ausfall wegen dem Fehler
da müssen wir Retrospektive machen, Prozesse etablieren und das ganz dringend nachbereiten
dass dieser Fehler auf gar keinen Fall wieder vorkommt
was ist jetzt los? und dann wundern sie sich, so nach dem Motto, pro Bug eine Abmahnung
und dann wundern sie sich, wenn keiner was sagt
Nö, bei uns nichts geplagt
das haben wir total oft, auf der einen Seite sind sie, ja ja wir sind alles nur Menschen, ist überhaupt kein Problem
und letztens am Montag ist ein Kollege von mir was passiert, der hat sich einfach bei den Servernamen verschrieben
der hat F statt G geschrieben in dem Servernamen
der hat sich vertippt, weil die Servernamen auch so bescheuert sind
und da machen die jetzt eine riesen Aktion nach dem Motto, uns ist mindestens, frag mich nicht, 5 Tage mehr Arbeit dadurch entstanden
ich mein das war Montag wohlgemerkt, heute ist Mittwoch
ja gut, wo kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten, uns ist mindestens 5 Tage mehr Arbeit dadurch entstanden
und ganz schlimm und furchtbar, dann muss sich doch keiner wundern, wenn die Leute da nichts mal sagen wollen
wir legen uns erstmal eine Fake E-Mail Adresse an, exzellent
wie war das nochmal auf Aliexpress wegen dem Versand?
also am besten ist wenn du Banggood EU Priority Line machst
Aliexpress musst du auch sowas ähnliches wie Priority Line machen, dass sie das nicht direkt aus China an dich schicken
sondern aus China in die Niederlande oder nach Spanien oder sonst wo und von da an dich, dann passiert mit soll nichts
hast du das Video geguckt?
erscheint so, erscheint so
den gibt es übrigens immer noch, den Geistersaber
ok also, wir machen uns jetzt mal einen LinkedIn Account, hab ich schon nie gemacht, also exzellent
LinkedIn, mit was? E-Mail auf Phone-Number
ok
kann man das einfach so machen?
join with Google, null
ok, sollten wir da jetzt irgendwie was reinschreiben, was realistisch klingt oder ist das zum gucken egal?
Max
Todschatte
das muss so klingen, als ist das irgendwie ein Inder oder so
da krieg ich noch, da krieg ich noch, da krieg ich noch Mails, wo drinne steht wie man die Nachnamen ausspricht
Max, Todschatte, Todschatte sind wir, Todschatte
es muss ja so klingen, es darf nicht Q-Chat direktheisen
ok, continue
ich hab, ich hab, Leute ich hab mich da noch nie registriert, ich hab, was?
Check-Wait, was wollt ihr von mir? Please solve this puzzle
ok, let's touch the image that is correct way up, das oder?
oh, wie das wars?
63450, nein das ist nicht, wir gucken für Frankfurt
in Frankfurt
das darf ruhig rein meinen seins, auch ok
leaked, schon wieder leaked
most recent job title, ok wir übertreiben, wir übertreiben jetzt mal ein bisschen
senior devops architect
schreibt man das, schreibt man, ich glaub schreibt man mit C oder?
ok, ich hab keine Ahnung ob es diese Kombination gibt, die Kombination gibt es bestimmt
die Kombination gibt es bestimmt
hey child
das ist mir zu dumm, das mach ich nicht
was?
was, das drei
geht euch nix an
select industry
ah hier, computer hardware, computer software
computer software, aha
wie viel? 9 millionen
9, fast 10 millionen, sind das fake user?
wirecard
ich schreib da gar nichts, next
was?
screen confirmed, excellent, excellent
ich will es nicht mailen
wann ist dein Geburtstag?
1337, können wir das irgendwie machen?
naja, nicht wirklich
69, das ist gut
das ist der neunte Monat, September, ah Moment, 69
continue
wow
wo mein Abit
aha, alles klar
das sind die, die ich angeblich kenne oder was?
ich kann davon nicht ein
ok, ich bin, ach skippen kann man das
Max Kutter Chatte ist am Start
add photo, ok Moment, wir brauchen irgendein Stockfoto
man
excellent, irgendein Stockfoto von irgendeinem Dude
jazebaro, ja
ich hab ne Idee
das Suppen League Bild rein
wo ist das Max liegt, aus der Suppe
ok zebaro, was gibt's?
ganz bestimmt zebaro, ganz bestimmt
ok, passt
perfekt
bisschen schräg noch
excellent
sehr gut, das ist der perfekte User dafür
perfekt
so ist top
zebaro sagt, ich lache echt, das muss man im Internet schon dabei sagen, das ist wichtig
weil im Internet schreiben so viele Leute keck, weh, lull und sitzen in Wirklichkeit so vorm Rechner
Bill Gates soll ich folgen, natürlich
der alte Bill natürlich, wir kennen uns ja schon lang
wer ist denn Ali K. Miller
das ist Hot Software Grill
den müssen wir gleich followen
ja der hat mir noch gefehlt jetzt alter
der hat mir noch gefehlt jetzt
ok, ist alles langweilig, wo sehe ich denn jetzt was für Stellanzeigen gibt
ah ne, ne hier, finish, finish
also ich hab legit keinen Plastenschimmer davon
ich hab das noch nie verwendet
ich hoffe die Leute können mich jetzt hier nicht einfach ans
das Profil alter
ist LinkedIn nicht sowas, wo sie alle furchtbar business und serious sind
ich werde wahrscheinlich gleich gebannt
ok, da tragen wir jetzt sogar mal was halbwegs realistisches an
ach so, Moment, das ist vielleicht das letzte
ich glaub sogar 2012, die wissen ja nicht wo
build your network, get notified about new jobs
ok Moment, ich will nicht Premium machen, aber ich will
was, warum
sind das jetzt Essentials oder ist das Premium
das ist so für mich so ein Ding, Premium Essentials
das machen sie gerne, das passt überhaupt nur zusammen
for anyone who wants to excel professionally
solange es nicht mit Excel ist
Pinstchamp, ich weiß
99 im Jahr oder 10 Euro im Monat
zweimal more profile views
ja wahrscheinlich weil ich oben stehe oder so
ich glaube ganz ehrlich
also als würde es die Anzahl der Recruiter Messages irgendwie ausmachen
wichtig ist doch, dass man was kriegt, was passt
ob ich jetzt noch mehr Spambot Messages kriege ist doch egal
alles klar
Send Messages oder
Hä, Moment
man kann, man kann Leuten
die nicht mit einem befreundet sind oder followen
oder sich gegenseitig followen oder wie auch immer
keine Nachrichten schicken, sehe ich richtig
wie können einem dann die ganzen Recruiter Dudes
dann Nachrichten schicken
erstmal Bill Gates zu spam
gibt es nicht so ein Feature bar Tinder
Tinder ist noch das wo man hin und her wischt
rank yourself
okay wir gucken uns jetzt die Jobanzeigen an
Chat, ich lerne hier auch noch was
ich lerne hier auch noch was
wie gesagt ich habe das noch nie verwendet
aber wir haben schon mal ein super serious Profil Bild
du musst networken dafür aber
du kannst auch eine Seite haben wie Fanpage auf Facebook
Eric hat mich in
was, wo
wo hat mich Eric invited
Eric hast mich excellent accept
auf gehts
du bist bestimmt aus dem Stream oder
der Eric da ist er
du bist das warum heißt du dann Joseph im Stream
ich rieche Tübet
wir wissen ja, wir wissen ja, wir wissen ja
bekanntlichermaßen weil das immer
Internet, Internet Nicknames immer in echt damit
übereinstimmen
ich bin es, ich bin es
war mir klar ihr seid ihr seid das alle
so okay
Jobs, Search
Premium Jobs
ach ne
try free
scheiß drauf
wir tryn das jetzt for free ist überhaupt kein Problem
ich hab da keine Zahlungsinformation hinterlegt
easy
als weiß ich mein Passwort jetzt noch
ha natürlich weiß ich mein Passwort noch
kann nicht mehr tippen
let's do a quick security das muss ich jetzt jedes mal mal einloggen machen
verstehe
ne ne okay ist gut ich lass bleiben LinkedIn
okay Jobs
Leute ich guck ich guck nicht in die Messages kann man Bilder in den Messages schicken
so
der nächste hat mich geadded
CEO
bei Paydingdong
Paydingdong
es gibt ernsthaft ne Firma die Paydingdong heißt
den accepte ich jetzt
das ist bestimmt auch
okay also Jobs
exzellent
ich muss jetzt danach so ob es das gibt
Paydingdong
das ist irgendwie ein fake account
das ist ja genau der Zahlungsservice von Banggood
ich mach das das nächste Mal unter Linux hier vielleicht hat das noch irgendwelche
Remote Execution sonst wie Gedöns
also alles klar Jobs jetzt can't wait endlich
search bei
DevOps engineer gucken wir jetzt was was gibt's hier
trainee all all genders oder habe ich aber noch Glück gehabt
dass ich da als Keks dran teilnehmen kann
promoted
warum ist die Seite eigentlich nur so halb
warum geht die Seite eigentlich nicht über einen kompletten Bildschirm
beinahe nur
wäre das nicht irgendwie sinnvoll dass man den
den space ausnutzt
ich soll nach Cobol okay das machen wir jetzt
der nächste ist am Start
alles da werden alle accepted
Jobs ich suche jetzt nach Cobol Cobol
Cobol
ich finde die Seite sieht sogar gar nicht übel aus
Mainframe Experte modernisierung Cobol Mainframe Entwickler
Leute das ist doch was für uns
ich nachdem ich jetzt fortgeschrittene Cobol Kenntnisse habe
ist ist doch eigentlich klar
ist der nächste Karriere Schritt
also im was im Bereich
ist issuing production support
also issuing sind ja Probleme weil die sagen ja nicht Problem die sagen ja Issue
aber was ist denn
issuing production support
im Kartenmanagement ich habe keine Ahnung was das sein soll
Lochkarten
aber REX oh das sind auch immer so geile Sachen ja gibs mir
ach issuing ist Ausgabe
ah ok das ergibt das ergibt Kartenausgabe und sowas ja das ergibt Sinn
das sieht aber normal aus da kann man sich nicht so sehr drüber übel machen
was was passiert was gibt es immer nach Agile Sucht
Senior Master
was soll denn das sein
Senior Agile Master
ich glaube ich stelle mir was falsches drunter vor
Agile Master
wie heißt die Cognizant
das kann ich nicht immer aussprechen
Cognizant
alles klar
schnelles Wachstum und internationale und innovative Umgebung
oder Umfeld
so ganz viele Möglichkeiten wie Leute wie mich
ich sag es euch jemand wie Max Kudorcz hatte
der ist so einer
kannst du den Chat kleiner machen
ah der Chat ist da drüber
ich mach einfach so
wisst ihr was wir machen jetzt Big Brain
wenn der Chat im Weg ist nachdem die Seite
nachdem die Seite eh nicht Fullscreen ist machen wir einfach so
jetzt zoomen wir noch ein bisschen ran schon haben wir voll die Seite ausgenutzt
jetzt ist zu groß
ich muss in der Vorschau gucken
ja sieht passend aus
excellent
sehr responsive
was Sebaru du musst eine Telefonnummer eingeben
komisch
also was macht man dann als Agile Master
da steht im Prinzip nichts
About Your Role
Senior Agile Master DFM
ach die wäre es
ich bin verwirrt weil das andere F und M ist
bei uns steht ja immer WMD
könnt ihr euch erinnern Black Ops 1 gab es eine Map die WMD hieß
also ich werde Leuten
Agile Theory Best Practices Regeln und Werte beibringen
weil ich selber so agil bin ich bin Agile Master
ich coach alle
was muss man eigentlich für einen Typ sein dass man so einen Job macht ich kann das nicht verstehen dass das Leute freiwillig machen
ist ja nicht mein Problem kann jeder kann jeder machen was er will
irgendwie ein Kult ein bisschen ja
doch ich weiß was das für Leute sind ich weiß was das für Leute sind
wir hatten mal ein Projekt da war auch so ein super agiler Projekt Manager dabei
und er hat es der hat es nicht verstanden dass die Leute nach der Arbeit nichts mehr
dass er hat es nicht verstanden ich habe gesagt er hat es verstanden ich meine er hat es nicht verstanden
dass die Leute nach der Arbeit nichts mehr mit der Arbeit zu tun haben wollen
und er hat dann gesagt wisst ihr beim Projektabschluss dann machen wir was richtig cooles
ich kann sein dass ich schon mal erzählt habe und haben wir uns schon gedacht oh ne oh ne please
lass uns einfach in ruhe wir wollen nichts cooles machen es ist fertig es ist vorbei
wir machen was richtig cooles und dann hat er zu uns gesagt wir gehen zusammen in den Kletterpark
und da haben wir uns alle nur so gedacht
tschüss dich Aldo
genau wisst ihr was wir da gedacht haben Leute
fick dich weg du homoforst
genau zumindest haben wir dann gab es ein Problem dabei
und irgendjemand aus diesem Projektteam hat sich ertreistet zu fragen ob das denn dann auch als Arbeitszeit abgerechnet werden kann
und er hat wahrscheinlich so in der Richtung gesagt wie kann das als Arbeitszeit abgerechnet werden
wahrscheinlich hat er jetzt auch noch dazu gesagt er hat da keinen bock drauf
der war der war der Typ war übelst stinkig weil auch sein also ich kann das verstehen ohne Scheiß
ich kann den verstehen also ich kann nicht verstehen wie man das machen will aber ich kann den Typ verstehen
für den war das wirklich was cooles war das wirklich eine Belohnung
und er hat sich da voll Mühe gegeben dass das Geld dafür genehmigt wird und alles
aber wir hatten da halt keinen bock drauf am Ende am Ende ist es drauf rausgelaufen dass wir alle einmal essen gegangen sind
da sind wir 15 Uhr rübergegangen in so ein Restaurant haben alle mal ordentlich gefressen dann war gut wunderbar
Heinrich 10 monat dankeschön für den Sub
Massive Subscriptions hier Leute ich glaube ich habe ein paar übersehen ich gucke jetzt nochmal schnell
das Serious Max hat nämlich auch abonniert vor 50 Minuten war das schon ich habe es nicht gesehen
für die Subs so ich glaube jetzt habe ich nichts mehr übersehen also gut also das ist das was moment moment moment moment moment
ich bin Agile Master warum muss ich denn dann einen Judemi Kurs machen wie man Agile ist
kenne du Team Spirit ein offenes wie nennt man das auf Deutsch so schön Blablabla Mentalität Anpack Mentalität oder sowas
weiß nicht wie man das wie man das gescheit übersetzen soll Macher ein Macher ein Enabler wie man das so schön zu sagt
Neudeutsch dazu das ist auch schon mal gehört das ist auch so ein neues Buzzword ein Enabler
Leute ich denke mir die Scheiße nicht aus ich gebe das nur wieder
ok das ist klar das ist drum Leute
was ist da wie kann das sein wie gemacht für mich ok hier hatte einer keinen Bock zu formatieren
einfach format hat man weggelassen das ist vollkommen egal das lese ich jetzt nicht das kann doch keiner
was passiert wenn man sich da bewirbt wie geht das eigentlich ich habe den Kram noch nie benutzt
Expleo das war jetzt eh nur aus Spaß gucken wir mal was sinnvolles
Guck mal das Kram Master was auf meinen Job alles matcht
Du begleitest unsere Kunden beim Einführen so so ach so etablieren und mögliche Agile Methoden alles klar
Ok jetzt gucken wir uns mal was sinnvolles an ich habe eine Nachricht gekriegt
Man kriegt eine Nachricht wenn mal ein Profil angeschaut wird
Wie da kann man nicht mal Leute stalken oder so also stalken ist jetzt das falsche Wort ihr wisst was ich meine
Zum Beispiel würde ich jetzt gleich mal nach unserem Spezial Azubi gucken der danach Junior Consultant geworden ist
Und also nicht on stream jetzt aber da sieht ihr ja dass ich geguckt habe wenn ich da wirklich angemeldet wäre
Dass ich kann gar nicht rumbrusen ohne dass das einer sieht
So ein bisschen die alten Teammates stalken was die heute machen ohne dass sie gleich sehen dass ich auf dem Profil war
Würde ich dann schon machen wenn ich hier schon einen Account habe
Aber man kann das einstellen ok ok DevOps Engineer Darmstadt Hessen Germany das ist doch was für mich
Warum kann mir eigentlich LinkedIn nicht anhand meines Job Titels Jobs vorschlagen ohne dass ich danach suchen muss
Ach doch hier ne das sind die alten Sachen die ich gesucht habe
Ach da brauch ich das Premium für
Max was ist dein Gehalt das kann ich dir nicht sagen aus mehreren Gründen
Das erste ich weiß nicht ob ich es genau ob ich es exakt sagen darf
Und das zweite ist ich weiß es gar nicht exakt aber ich kann dir sagen dass ich
Oh fuck ich weiß es gar nicht dass ich im Tarifvertrag bin für Versicherungsgewerbe Frankfurt
Und ich Stufe Top 6 bin mit 14 Monats Gehältern
Das heißt dann hast du schon mal das unterste was mindestens sein muss
Wer will dir das denn verbieten mein Arbeitsvertrag
Ich weiß dass das eventuell rechtlich so nicht geht aber da lasse ich mich nicht drauf ein
So wo gibt es denn hier das Sachen
Im Moment das Scrum Master
Ich hab doch eben was für mich passendes gefunden wo ist denn das jetzt auf einmal hier
Woina 14 Dankeschön Twitch Prime
Exzellent
Und was ist mit Doktor Kabum warum hat er aufgehört das musst du selber fragen das kann ich dir nicht sagen warum er genau aufgehört hat
Ich kann dir so sagen dass jetzt was mit Auto Stonks Auto im Stonks Autobusiness am Start ist
Der muss nicht mehr in die Gruppe der kriegt das auch so hin
Also was wollen sie jetzt
Deine Aufgaben dein Profil Management und Betrieb des Kubernetes
Ist das ein bisschen komischer Satz oder ist die Seite kaputt
Die haben den Kram wieder nicht formatiert richtig
Ok Management und Betrieb des Kubernetes
Alles klar nicht Clusters einfach nur das das Kubernetes
Ok man weiß was gemein ist Studium der Informatik oder eine
Cluster und WTF
Wer hat das denn eingestellt
In Deutschland werden die Gehälter überall nur 12 mal bezahlt bei uns sind es 14
Management und Betrieb des
Das ist total komisch Copy Pasted Studium
Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn also Management und Betrieb des Kubernetes
Clusters unsere Software lösen berufsrelevante aus
Wer hat das denn zusammen Copy Pasted ist doch total kaputt
Das kann man sich so ungefähr zusammen reimen
Wie gesagt
Wer das mindeste wissen will der guckt sich an
Was der Tarifvertrag für Versicherungsgewerbe
Da Frankfurt AGV irgendwas hat
Ich glaube ich bin Stufe 6 mit maximalen mit maximalen
Berufsjahren Stufe 6 oder Stufe
Hauptstufe 6
Ok wisst ihr was wenn ich es genau wissen wollte ich gucke jetzt nach
Also ich gucke mich nach was ich was ich exakt verdiene das bin ich mir jetzt sicher ob ich euch sagen darf
Aber der Tarifvertrag das darf ich euch sagen
Tarifvertrag Versicherungs
Versicherungsgewerbe ist es das das da genau
So
Mandeltarifvertrag der ab dem Juli geltenden Verfassung nicht Verfassung Fassung
So und da sind irgendwo Tabellen drin
Irgendwo
Oder auch nicht
Nee da gab es das eigenes für
Halt
Was ist denn
Ah ja der da genau
Nee das ist was anderes der da ist das der richtige
Also gültig seit 1 April 2020
Gehaltsgruppe 6
Und
Nee 7 definitiv nicht ich glaube 6
Ja jaja jaja 6
Und ich bin
14 Jahre da also
Ich habe maximale Jahre wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich schon mehr
Wie gesagt ich habe Ausbildung in 2007 gemacht und die haben das auch davor noch umgerechnet das ist alles
Proton natürlich natürlich
So also
Kriege ich mindestens das hier ist das im Monat
Monatsbezüge also kriege ich mindestens das hier mal
Übrigens 4 3 2 1 ernsthaft
Das ist ja mal ein geier Betrag
Und das mal 14
So genau so
Also sprich das ist das mindeste
Was ich bekomme
Allerdings muss jetzt müsst ihr das umrechnen
Auf 4 Tage
Das heißt es ist noch weniger
Und
Da kommt noch ein bisschen was dabei was ich jetzt aber nicht habe was ich euch aber nicht sage
Also wir haben noch individuellen Bonusgedöns im Vertrag das sage ich euch aber nicht
Aber jetzt wenn ich es also für alle die wissen wollen das ist das mindeste
Was ich aktuell kriege
Und genau weiß ich es nicht
Genau weiß ich es wirklich nicht ich habe keine Ahnung
Wirklich nicht
Wie wird man Stufe 7 8 9 Stufe 9 gibt es glaube ich doch Stufe 9 gibt es
Das kommt drauf an auf die jeweilige Firma
Nach meiner Kaufmenschen Ausbildung mache ich IT Ausbildung wie findest du das
Frage ist ob du es brauchst
Ok also die Anzeige ist bescheuert ist ja noch nicht mal richtig copy pasted wir hatten das gemacht
Deine Aufgabe in deinem Profil das ist total wild zusammen copy pasted das kann man doch nicht mal lesen
Motiviert das internationale was dich flacher erschien flexible Vertrauensarbeitszeit darf man das überhaupt noch
Ich dachte man muss Zeit Erfassung mittlerweile so und so machen
Zumindest hat die HR Frau MWD
Ich sage jetzt mal Frau weil in der Personal Abteilung bei uns zu 95% Frauen sind
Ist nicht so mit copy pasten
Kostenloses Obst ungetrennt Kicker unsinnig ist immer auf offene Ohren was
Immer auf offene Ohren
Du hast sehr gute Deutsch und gute motiviert das Team das ist so kaputt copy pasted was haben die denn gemacht
Bewerb dich jetzt mit Angaben eine verfügbarkeit neukarriere auta da auta da
Ok was gibt was gibt Flixbus Flixbus da wollte ich schon immerhin
Ein Senior Support Tooling Engineer exquisite
Paint the world green
Ok was machen sie konfigurieren also konfigure deploy monitor maintain our tools
Hier es heißt übrigens hier Leute ich muss das an der Aso der Chat der Chat ist ja wieder im Weg
So kann ich glaube ich mache kann ich eigentlich so machen oder ist dann im Weg
Jetzt ist im Weg ich mache einfach so
Jetzt haben wir es aber ganz genau jetzt ist optimal space ausgenutzt
So es heißt es heißt hier das kommt vom japanischen aber es sagen alle mittlerweile
Jaira oder sowas Jaira Jaira Jaira Jaira Jaira
Das ist der beste desktop den es gibt
Ok Flix Streamline integration das Fenster triggert mich wenn ich das Fenster nicht ganz sehe deswegen muss ich bisschen kleiner machen
Ok das ist alles in Ordnung
Man erkennt Failedinger sofort irgendwie
Das sieht auch alles relativ normal aus
Ok was wollen sie haben
Das ist das ist ja schon richtig old school was ist datadog das ist eine Metrik Sammel wie nennt man das
Metrik Sammel und Analyse Service Lock Metrik Sammel Analyse Service
Ok das ist natürlich auch wieder ein bisschen viel
Sie wollen auf der einen Seite dass du CICD machst dass du Cloud Infrastructure machst dass du offline Infrastructure machst
Dass du IT Prozesse optimierst und Rufbereitschaft machst ok
Hast du dich nach der Ausbildung eigentlich noch weiter gebildet ich bilde mich permanent weiter weil wenn man sich aufhört weiter zu bilden dann zackt man irgendwann
Auch Kirby Musik ist vorbei
Ok das ist aber auch noch recht normal was benutzen sie bei Beard denn
AngularX was ist denn AngularX ich kenne Angular ich kenne das alte AngularJS was ist das 10 was ist AngularX
TypeScript ah siehste NGAX
Ok das sagt mir wenigstens noch was Reactive Testing Ok hätte ich keine Ahnung von hätte ich auch keine Ahnung von ich kenne die.NET AX Extensions das ist mit JavaScript nicht viel Unterschied
Testing Gedöns ist überall das gleiche SAS kriege ich mittlerweile auch hin
So was machen die Backend Pysons Flask die haben ganz viel Pysons Zeug am Start hier
Ist das nicht anders ist das nicht das heißt wirklich Slytheri das war ein Sentry nochmal irgendein Monitoring Ding oder
Das ist aber auch nicht sonderlich spannend das ist ziemlich normal es gibt ein Fitness Studio Membership
Ne gibt es noch nicht Doktor Worst ich wusste gar nicht dass das so begehrt ist habe ich jetzt schon ein paar Leute nachgefragt Ok dann gibt es noch Han Ham also quasi Schinken
Warum ist das da alles auf Englisch ich verstehe es ja irgendwo aber auf diesen ganzen Noob Shop Seiten ist das alles auf Deutsch und dann auch noch teilweise übel schlecht eingedeutscht
Sentry ist doch ein Framer für Exception Overview das kann sein ich kann mir bringen das nicht alles unter einen Hut immer es gibt so viel Zeug
Ok das ist aber auch noch alles recht normal das sieht man da ist nichts drinne mit 12 Jahre Kubernetes Experience und sowas
Ok die können wir nicht copypasten ein Cloud Chameleon das ist doch auch mal was ich habe wieder eine neue Netzwerk Anfrage easy
Oh Mist ich wollte annehmen wie geht das kann man das vorbei ich nehme euch alle an
Also das Cloud Chameleon Cloud Architekt Cloud Software Engine Cloud Was Ok Ok die übertreiben es jetzt aber gleich mal wieder richtig
Ich meine ich meine nur weil nur weil du 5 verschiedene Bereiche nimmst die alle was anderes sind ja und du schreibst Cloud vor jedem dieser Begriffe
Dann macht es doch nicht zu einem also ich meine die suchenden Architekt nennt Software Entwickler nennt Security Experten Mensch System Mann und Netz das muss ich mir speichern das ist top
Das muss ich mir mal speichern für Video aber ich meine ernsthaft du kannst doch nicht einfach Cloud davor schreiben dass es für alle dann funktioniert
Cloud Enabler genau das hat jetzt noch gefehlt so also das ist das ist schon mal ein bisschen zu viel für eine Person was schreiben sie hier im Intro
Die Digitalisierung stellt viele Unternehmen vor neue Herausforderungen für dieses innovative Denk Schemata und neue Herangehensweisen Bedarf
Ich meine man das ist ein korrekter Satz aber irgendwie klingt sehr übertrieben innovativer Denk Schemata innovativer Herangehensweise verstehe
Übrigens das wo ich das hier gerade lese wusstet ihr dass dieser dieser ich glaube Boom kann man es nicht nennen aber das ist so viele so viele Startups und so viele erfolgreiche kleineren IT Dinger in den letzten Jahren gab
Wisst ihr woran das liegt habe ich einen echt interessanten Artikel drüber gelesen und zwar nicht etwa weil wir in Deutschland auf jeden Fall auf einmal anfangen super innovatives Zeug zu machen und total competitive und wettbewerbsfähig und alles sind
Das liegt schlicht nur greifen daran dass wir so viel große alte Unternehmen haben die mittlerweile so hoffnungslos den Anschluss verloren haben dass sie ohne Hilfe von so kleinen Läden die sich auskennen gar nicht mehr es schaffen Anschluss zu bekommen
Also sprich unser wir sind deswegen gut weil wir im anderen Bereich so schlecht sind eigentlich voll von Arsch aber mindestens 12 Jahre Kubernetes Erfahrung
Okay
Die schreiben das sogar noch du bist die Eier legende Wollmilchsau im Google Cloud Umfeld Cloud Architektur Software Engineering Security und weiß deine Kommunikationsstärke in Zusammenarbeit mit diversen Stakeholder
Das heißt du musst die Typen auch noch von dem überzeugen was du machst aus Data Architektur Engineering Science und Bbi was ist Bbi Business Business Intelligence Ah jawoll Stonks und mit den Kollegen ein geiles Produkt zu formen
Okay die schreiben das wenigsten schon so dass du weißt das ist eine komplette No Life Stelle das schreiben die wenigsten so das ist eine Stelle du arbeitest 24 7 und wenn du Glück hast hast du nach ein paar Jahren übelst viel Geld
Hoffen wir mal hoffen wir hoffen wir mal zumindest hoffen wir mal also die wollen alle alles kann steigung der Nutzbarkeit und des Impacts der Daten für die Weile okay das sagt nichts sagen Konzeption und Umsetzung einer Business Intelligence Plattform in der Google Cloud gemeinsam mit zahlreichen Kunden
Das kann ja auch alles heißen
Aus Data Architektur und Data Science auch noch Gewährleistung eines einheitlichen Daten Verständnis Transparenz entlang der Datenverständnis da kannst du dir nichts runter vorstellen Einhalte von Recht und Regula
Du musst jetzt du musst jetzt auch noch Rechtsexperte sein dass du das machen kannst
Auch gut vielleicht vielleicht weil ansonsten hätten sie zumindest noch schreiben können in Zusammenarbeit mit unserer Rechts Abteilung oder sowas
Das ist das ist das perfekte perfekte Job für den Jura abbrechenden Informatik Student der nebenbei noch alles sich selbst beigebracht hat
Und 19 ist
Ich muss gleich mal gucken wie groß dieser Laden ist
Das gewünschte Profil aber das reicht noch nicht du bringst ein mit überdurchschnittlichem Erfolg abgeschlossenes jetzt die wollen es wissen Nupes Nupes Not Wellcome
Okay okay du begeistert dich für Cloud Infrastrukturen
Du verfügst über Erfahrung Infrastructure as Code das ist ja das neue Basswörter für Puppet Ansible Chef und solche Geschichten
Früher hat man einfach gesagt Server Automatisierung oder sowas heute ist das Infrastructure as Code weil das cooler ist
Betriebs Automatisierung und der Skalierung Cloud basierter verteilt ja okay das bla bla bla
Kann im Prinzip wieder alles sein du hast da
Du hast Erfahrung in Design Implementierung Betrieb von Bild Release Automatisierung achso achso ja gut CIC machst du auch noch das passt aber lustigerweise
Also das da
Moment ist es Cloud Engineer okay aber du machst du machst du machst Continuous Integration
Continuous Integration machst du auch noch darüber hinaus verfügst du über ein ausgeprägtes Bewusstsein für IT Sicherheit
Und lässt dieses stets in das haben wir auch schon du bringst sehr gute Skripting Kenntnisse mit mit Bash Go Python und Tools wie Terraform
Okay das passt dazu Cloud in Ordnung saubere alles klar
Zählen deine Exzellenten ja das das kann ich Exzellent sind wir hier also zu deinen größten Stärken zählen deine exzellente konzeptionellen Fähigkeiten
Was sind denn exzellente konzeptionelle Fähigkeiten also ich kann gut gute Pläne erstellen oder so die dann auch funktionieren oder was
Eine schnelle Auffassung Skam und die Freude an der Zusammenarbeit mit einem weit verzweiten Team
Dein Kommunikation starkes Profil wird von sehr guten Kenntnissen
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt was die Jungs bezahlen wollen
Afterwork Events okay das lassen stecken Interesse geweckt um ehrlich zu sein
Aber ich will wissen was das war ja klar
Brain Talents ich muss ich muss mal ich muss mal kurz Brain Talents Hamburg ich muss mir kurz mal die Seite von denen angucke
Kann gut sein dass das keine echte Stelle aber warum machen die das dann wo ist da der Hintergrund
Wo ist da der Hintergrund werden die Fake Stellenanzeigen machen oder
Was haben die für eine Bewertung bei Google
In Köln haben die
Was sagt mir nichts was soll das sein
Also einfach mal auf gut Glück falls mir irgendein findet der der alles kann und das billig macht oder was
Ach so okay also quasi einfach mal gucken was man kriegt
Personalvermittlung ja okay dann kann natürlich sein ja
Brain Talents
Alles auf 450 Euro Basis
Das ist so ein Personalverschacherungs Ding ja also zumindest das ist halt echter Witz also
Also das kann ich ernst gemeint sein
Das das das kann das kann ich ernst gemeint sein das ist eigentlich das ist so abgedreht
Okay guck mal weiter klaut noch ein Cloud Engineer
Du hast das Video gefunden nice
Okay das sieht doch schon deutlich normaler aus hier
Das ist halt aktuell gerade angesagter Scheiß ja
Okay alles alles klar alles klar
Ja abgeskippt das Skipping das Skippen mit Pausen best in ihrem Fall alles in Ordnung
Die können alle die Stellenanzeigen nicht ordentlich formatieren oder da fehlt immer irgendwie was
Okay das liest sich halbwegs normal jetzt nicht unbedingt was man das unbedingt machen will aber das
Pass auf die schicken dem jetzt die schicken den Typen jetzt eine E-Mail das Max Kutte
Kutte Schatte möchte Stelleninformationen haben
Hugo Boss gibt es das noch das ist überhaupt nicht mal angesagt dachte ich Hugo Boss
Übrigens mal jetzt kurz kurze wie sag ich hier so so so
Es wird ja gesagt das angeblich Hugo Boss Uniform für die Wehrmacht im Zweiten Weltkrieg designt hat
Das stimmt nicht das sieht man unter ganz vielen Videos stimmt aber einfach nicht
Aber die Leute meinen das ernst der hat Uniform produziert aber da hat die Uniform nicht designt
Also die Firma hat das produziert und der hat natürlich auch davon profitiert aber was da unter Videos
Geschrieben wird so nach dem Motto Nice Hugo Boss Design so stimmt überhaupt nicht
Auch das Video vom Panzermuseum geschaut das kann sein dass das vom Panzermuseum war ja ich
Kannte das vorher gar nicht aber als ich das Video geguckt habe mir auch gefallen ja das hast du schon
Paar mal gelesen und stimmt aber nicht stimmt nicht
So Übrigens meine Erfahrung mit Hugo Boss also mit den mit den Klamotten bezieht sich auf eine Packung
Unterhosen die ich mir gekauft habe frag mich nicht in welch geistiger Umnachtung ich mich befunden habe
Dass ich mir überteuerte Hugo Boss Unterhosen gekauft habe ich habe mir zumindest ein Pack Hugo Boss
Unterhosen gekauft und die waren nach zweimal waschen war der Gummi im Arsch
Das war die schlechtesten ohne Mist die schlechtesten und gleichzeitig teuersten Unterhosen
Siebaro nicht wörtlich im Arsch aber Wuppgesum ja
Weiß ich was das war 5er Pack oder 10er Pack und zweimal gewaschen und nach dem ersten Mal hast du schon
gemerkt war der Gummi irgendwie teilweise nicht ausgeleiert spröde und sonst wie also totaler Müll
Dafür dafür sah es wahrscheinlich stylisch aus ja
Ok was was sucht Hugo Boss sie suchen einen DevOps Engineer genau das richtige für mich
Oh man sieht sogar wie viel sich beworben haben das heißt so schnell bewerben hier morgen gibt es nichts mehr
Die suchen mich ich weiß die suchen alle mich hier steht ja immer passt auf mich
Aber wenn man sich überlegt das LinkedIn da dran wahrscheinlich auch noch irgendwas verdient
LinkedIn sagt mal Leute LinkedIn wird doch garantiert was verdienen wenn die jemand vermitteln oder
Also was was suchen die was suchen die also wir und fashion bla bla bla bei uns bla bla bla ok sie arbeiten gemeinsam mit
Also was suchen sie einen DevOps Engineer sie arbeiten gemeinsam mit Software Entwicklern und Lösungs
Lösungsarchitekten wahrscheinlich heißen die bei denen aber dann Solution Architekt weil das cooler klingt
Um professionelle integrationslösung in einem Multicloud Umfeld zu planen zu entwerfen ok klingt normal
Beziehungsweise recht vage aber noch im Rahmen alles sie entwickeln Konzepte und Methoden zur Automatisierung
Ja auch ok sie unterstützen bei der Entwicklung und Einhalt auch ok
Die Arbeiten im Team souverän an Eskalation und Lösung kritischer Probleme wie arbeitet man souverän an Eskalation
Erstmal ordentlich auf den Tisch hauen das ist schön eskaliert einem ist klar was sie damit meinen
Aber das klingt immer ein bisschen doof wenn das so geschrieben ist rage quit rage quit die Arbeiten im Team souveräner Eskalation
rage quit und lösen kritische Probleme die sich auch ok das ist auch in Ordnung alles das ist ihr profil also
Studium Ausbildung mehrere Berufserfahrungen GitOps was ist das für eine Kombination
Das sind dann DevOps Leute die
Warum geht das automatisch auf will keine automatisch sich öffnen messages haben
Ich glaube das war nur weil ich gleichzeitig geklickt habe
Hier kann man doch bestimmt offline gehen oder
Ich kann es hier nicht auf away schalten oder so message settings
Was jetzt los
Was auch immer das von mir will zumindest kriegst du jetzt keine neuen messages
Das ist das ließ sich doch alles relativ normal bei Hugo Boss
Ich meine es ist jetzt nicht so verhandlungssicheres englisch okay
Der cute mod ist da jetzt wird gebannt Leute
Made for me das ließ sich doch relativ normal
Aber sich eigentlich auch offline
Jetzt ploppt nichts mehr auf exzellent
Ich lasse jetzt erst mal an
Okay also das ist normal das passt der junior engineer
Das sieht man im ersten Blick das sind normale Sachen
Aber die ersten waren geil die einfach alles gesucht haben
Okay wir suchen jetzt deutschlandweit wir suchen deutschlandweit
Wir suchen schon deutschlandweit kann das sein
Das ist nur sortiert da wo ich wohne
Oh die telekom sucht was cloud center of excellence suchen die
Was ist denn das cloud center of excellence
Entwickeln sie fortschrittliche technische ausbauen betrieb ja ja bla bla bla
Sie steuern die entwicklungsprozesse von hochkomplexen
Betreiben die alle immer so
Obwohl bei der telekom ist es wirklich hochkomplex das hört sich aber immer so wie eine auszeichnung an
Wie er bei uns machen das hochkomplex in wirklichkeit ist es so das müsste man vielleicht auch mal den ganzen
Stonks leuten sagen in wirklichkeit ist die kunst nicht was hochkomplexes zu bauen das funktioniert
Sondern was einfaches zu bauen was funktioniert
Glaubst du eigentlich dass die telekom was dass sie dass die lidl cloud besser wird als die telekom
Es gibt eine lidl cloud ernsthaft
stack it
Was ist das stack it
Das hat ja mit lidl nichts zu tun das ist das gehört im gleichen laden der lidl auch gehört ganz ehrlich
Aber was ist das für eine webseite die webseite ist ja schon mal fein du siehst da grad wo du draufklickst
Ach das liegt bestimmt hier aber im dark reader
Das liegt nicht am dark reader das ist einfach so schon kaputt aber man kann es zumindest besser erkennen
Pricing zeige hier cloud prices
What the fuck
Was ist das für ein preis sind hier noch bei zinn bei hetzer kostet es 2,98
Was letzte preis letzte preis ist definitiv zu hoch was ist denn mit euch los
Und das ist auch noch xs was ist denn dann was ist denn dann s
Lull
Was für ein schwachsinn
Das ist ein paar anderen mag das vielleicht ähnlich sein aber es gibt es auf jeden fall deutlich billiger
Das geht sogar
Das ist eigentlich ganz ok man bekommt ein halbes rack für 300 euro im monat
Das ist gar nicht so scheiße würde ich jetzt mal so aus dem bauch raus sagen
Also wenn man das brauche ist das glaube ich gar nicht schlecht
2 terabyte dann 5 cent ganz schön teuer
Was kostet ein rack normal im monat das weiß ich nicht was das so bei den meisten anderen anbietern kostet
Zumindest sind 299 relativ günstig sagt mir jetzt mein bauchgefühl ich kann es jetzt nicht genau sagen
Wir können mal gucken was es bei hetzer kostet das ihr bauch hat gerade link geschickt
Na gut bei hetzer kostet ein drittel rack 122 noch günstiger ok
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich vermutet dass das relativ günstig ist
Naja aber das ist schon echt teuer haben die denn keine simple pricing models dann zeigt doch mal das finde ich nämlich nicht simple
Zeigt mir einfach mal was habt ihr denn get in touch
Achso das gibt es noch gar nicht das ist einfach nur
Einfach nur da ok das ist sinnlos
Ich hatte italienische steuer bei hetzer
Ja gut aber es wird trotzdem es wird trotzdem nicht so viel kosten wie das andere
Wie viel es bei der telekom kostet das weiß ich nicht ok was
Also ich muss jetzt leute ich will jetzt wissen was das cloud center of excellence von der telekom möchte
Hochkomplexe bla bla bla bla schwerpunkt bild deployment jawoll
Noch mehr hochkomplexe infrastruktur und software
Ja kann man so sagen aber ist doch recht un unüblich
Wir sind verantwortlich für das aufsetzen automatisieren von hochkomplexen infrastrukturen
Einfach nur software und software
Man braucht da glaube ich gar keine mehrzahl von hochkomplexen infrastrukturen und software
Software braucht man gar nicht
Software innen vielleicht oder einfach nur software
Sie realisieren innovative infrastrukturlösung zum beispiel
Ja ja bla bla bla sie arbeiten eng mit alles klar
Ok das ist alles noch normal
Langjährige berufserfahrung ok jetzt jetzt kommt es jetzt geht los
Exzellente erfahrung in klassischen agilen kooperationsformen
Wenn die das bezahlen bin ich agil wie sonst was
Exzellente erfahrung in der leitung von strategischen übergreifen moment
Jetzt suchen sie auf einmal wieder den projektleiter
Ist bei der telekom jeder irgendwie projektleiter
Du hast neue nachrichten please know ja habe ich schon gesehen
Ich habe aber aufgeschaltet dass es auf ploppt
Also immer dieses exzellente ja falls weil die telekom sich für geil hält
Das wird das wird glaube ich noch nicht mal youtube video ich suche gerade sachen die man in dem youtube video
Verarbeiten könnte oder oder ich schneide aus dem stream zusammen ich bin nicht ganz sicher
Das nennt sich niedrige hierarchie jeder projekt manager das wird sein
So herausragend jetzt geht es wieder los herausragende
Kenntnisse in agilen entwicklungsmethoden beziehungsweise
Scrum kann kann ball und safe das habe ich schon wieder verdrängt
Da weiß da weiß ich gar nicht was es ist das war aber auch in so ein bullshit regelwerk oder
safe 5.0 scale a child framework genau da habe ich mal
Irgendwas drüber gehört 3 levels of safe
Scaled a child framework alles klar
Ich meine das sagt mir übrigens noch was das habe ich schon mal gehört aber kann
Jetzt aber nicht so richtig zuordnen letztendlich würden die sich alle mal
Ein bisschen besser besser tun wenn die sich weniger an
Irgendwelche regelwerken hochziehen würden sondern einfach gucken was zur jeweiligen firma passt
Und die leute nicht zu viel unsinnigen scheiß machen lassen sondern was sinnvolles
Wie gesagt gut gemacht ist das alles dagegen alles nichts
Einzuwenden aber viel übertreiben halt so nach dem motto das hier ist das 50
Billiarden seitliche eitel regelwerk wir machen jetzt eitel anstatt einfach mal
Zu gucken ok was ist davon sinnvoll
So herausragend kenne ich über defops technologie bis jetzt ist das in ordnung
Außer die außer die geschichte mit projektleitung verstehe ich nicht warum
Die jeden als projektleiter haben wollten
Das ist ok wir sind cloud enabler
Wuppe pock leute wuppe pock also für cloud enabler
Die sind das sind die sind exzellenz cloud enabler
2,95 im monat fast
Cloud enabler als surface hub center
Das haben sie aber noch abgekürzt
Die schmeißen mit begriffen um sich alle
Aber nicht surface surface ist vorbei als surface hub cloud center
Auf exzellenz ko
Das macht dann echt fertig genau wenn ich einer fragt wo
Arbeit du sagst na klar im ko oder wahrscheinlich ist das
C coi oder sie sowas stellen wir öffentlich cloud
Sonst
Die übertreiben es alle immer so
Full time yes
Die normal aus streaming skills ja die habe ich
Aber ich glaube die meinen was anderes
Soll ich da muss man sich bewerben und einfach die link zum live stream rein
Pasten hast du dir echt ein profil erstellt ja aber
Nicht so ganz legit wahrscheinlich bin ich morgen gebannt
Confluent kafka was ist das
Was ist
Confluent
Das kennt doch kein mensch
Reicht ja aber auch wenn man das produkt an sich kennt
Experience in database administration as well as big data systems
Ok ich ehrlich gesagt war mir nicht bewusst dass elastic search big data ist
Ich meine das erste sind ja eindeutig eindeutig die datenbanken
Und das ist jetzt big man es drei lass ich mir noch gefallen
Wobei es drei eigentlich eher so eine
Schnittstellen storage protokoll ne wir sollten was nennen so
Cloud storage kommunikationsgedöns ist
Aber was warum ist das jetzt auf einmal big data
Ich vermute einfach weil sich gut anhört
knowledge of a trance networking ok
SRE was ist SAE
Das meinen die jetzt aber nicht oder
Die meinen die meinen doch in den service
Oder meinen die weil das ist total durcheinander dann
Ok aws network engine x ist das ist
Ist er ist er das kenne ich warte mal was war das
Das sagt mir irgendwas
War das in proxy oder so
Ja das war in proxy
Wo ich doch komme bekannt vor prometheus das kennt ihr leute prometheus kennt ihr weil ihr kennt alle
Mein heizungsüberwachungs dashboard das ist unten drunter mit prometheus
Grafana der elk stack chat jetzt big brain
Was ist der elk stack wer weiß es
Weil die hälfte steht da oben schon das kann man sich da draus zusammen reiben
Elastik ja
Ich glaube das ist kibana genau
Elastik log stash kibana ja
Elastik search log stash kibana
Ja das weiß ich auch nur weil wir den elk stack bei uns auf der arbeit haben
Jäger sagt mir nichts
IT IT security experience
Oh aus re re bugs alter was
Manchmal ist es gut wenn man nicht so mit mit abkürzung übertreibt
Offers a cripple and competitive service dann sag doch was sache ist
Sagt doch einfach was sache sagt was es gibt zumindest zumindest mal so eine hausnummer
Die in wirklichkeit hoffen die doch eigentlich nur dass sie irgendeinen finden
Der das alles kann voll motiviert ist am besten noch frisch aus gelernt frisch aus studiert
Dass man ihn auch für die jeweilige firma gut gut umwursten kann
Und der dann irgendwie auch nur 25k will oder so
Das träumen sie wahrscheinlich vorne
Wir gehen jetzt einfach auf seite acht wir überspringen das jetzt mal ein bisschen
Frankfurt gibt es ganz schön viel ich sag's ja immer Frankfurt wo du hinspuckst ein rechenzentrum
Was ist ein gutes galt für das kann man überhaupt nicht sagen
Weil jeder die leute ein bisschen was anderes für machen lässt
Es kommt auf die region als kontra an was du machst
Wenn du einfach nur ein bisschen jenkins rumklickst was im endeffekt auch schon
In dem sinn ist ja was du zumindest darunter zählen kannst
Da ist jetzt so viel bei kommt drauf an was du machst in welche welche welche region das ist
Und begehrt das halt ist kann man jetzt echt schlecht sagen
Wir gehören zu den top adressen in der it welt
Okay ich muss ehrlich gesagt sagen ich habe davon noch nie was gehört aber das heißt ja auch nichts
Was wäre ein gutes gehalt für die eier legende wollen mich davon von also mal ohne scheiß
Diese eier legende wollen mich aus stelle wenn wenn das wirklich war da nicht sogar noch
Bereitschaft zur schichtarbeit drin oder war das eine andere stellen anzeigen
Also wenn sich da wirklich einer drauf bewirbt und das alles kann und am voll motiviert
Die müssen zumindest die müssen so 100k plus geben
Also wer das wirklich macht und kann
Und oder sogar noch mehr und und da auch noch gewillt ist das da 24 7 zu machen
Also das muss das muss eigentlich schon sechs stellig sein
Lohnt sich ja noch nicht mal für denjenigen der gibt den löffel ab nach fünf Jahren der das macht
Bis dahin muss man bisschen geld verdient haben
Okay was wollen die hier
Okay Consulting da geht schon wieder los
Deine rolle was ich erwarte ist du bist also was suchen sein
Consulten Infrastructure Automatisierung
Du bist Automatisierung Experte in
Achso
Soll ich mich verlesen
Du bist Automatisierung Experte in
Ich habe einfach gesagt du bist Automatisierung Experte in
Und kennst dich mit Infrastructure as Code
Das wie gesagt das ist das neue Basswort dafür
Konzepten mit Tools wie Chef, Puppet, Ansible, Solstack
Solstack scheint im Kommen zu sein
Das haben die bei der letzten Stellanzeige auch schon drin stehen gehabt
Da liegst du mit einem Start in unserem DevOps Team
Genau richtig
Alles in Ordnung
Alles alles vollkommen im Rahmen
Ja okay wenn man Server Admin ein bisschen gedulden ist klar
Ich mein die meisten Leute die so was wir machen gucken mich an
Die haben auch mal entweder was in Richtung Fahr-Informatik System Integration gelernt
Für Uhrzeiten oder waren auch mal Server Admin
Aber aus der Richtung
Bei mir ist halt das gute in dem Fall
Dass ich zwar Fahr-Informatik System Integration gelernt habe
Aber ich mich schon viel länger fürs Programmieren interessiere
Deswegen ist das für mich super das was ich jetzt machen kann
Deswegen programmiere ich auch kostenlos Android Apps am Wochenende für die Firma
Habe ich euch ja am Anfang erzählt
Braucht man ein Studium was oder geht eine Ausbildung geht auch eine Ausbildung ist kein Problem
Sofern du eben Erfahrungen in dem Bereich hast gar kein Ding
Nein ich habe am Anfang erzählt
Ich habe am Anfang erzählt ich habe was gemacht was ich sonst nie mache
Ich habe mich freiwillig dazu gemeldet
Freitag und Samstag bei so einem bei so einem Event in der Firma mitzumachen
Wo es darum geht innovat, also wer hat die beste Idee für eine Android App
Schleimer ja ist so
Ich weiß auch nicht warum ich damit mache normalerweise mache ich bei so freiwilligen Sachen nicht mit
Was war deine Idee das sage ich jetzt nicht sonst wird hier noch gestream sniped
Hast du Musik laufen ja
Recht leise aber
Ich habe wenigstens ein Emoji dahinter gemacht
Was ist eigentlich der heutige PogChamp
Den finde ich sogar ziemlich gut
Den finde ich echt gut
Weitere wisst ihr wisst ihr wie sich Twitch jede Menge Diskussion und und generve hätten ersparen können
In dem die einfach den alten PogChamp gelassen hätten
Weil ihr habt ja mitgekriegt der PogChamp von vor zwei Tagen oder so hat sich ja auch recht
Kritisch zur aktuellen Situation geäußert
Also das einfachste wäre gewesen
Sie hätten den alten PogChamp gelassen
Das ist einfach wie so ein Match zu bei allen Stellen anschauen ja das frage ich mich auch
Ja genau der Typ genau der Typ war das
Das weiß ich auch nicht warum ich bei allen Stellen Ausschreibungen match ich habe mein Profil nichts drin stehen
Außer dass ich doch in dem Fall passt dass es matcht
Außer dass ich DevOps ich habe schon vergessen was ich bin
Senior DevOps Solutions Architekt ich habe einen Bullshit reingeschrieben
Ja und die haben auch ganz viele Leute durch das Entfernen von PogChamp
Die Idee gebracht überhaupt mal zu gucken wer hinter PogChamp steht
Deine skills also das ist alles normal bisher
Kenntnisse von Sicherheitsstandards wie beispielsweise ISO 2700x
Chat Hand aufs Herz
Wer kennt ISO 2700x
Richtig die Frage ja das stimmt
Die Informationssicherheit ist durch die ISO
Das ist doch wieder so komplett useless Kram oder
Das ist sowas dass ich irgendwelche Management Leute freuen
Dass man sagen kann man hat jemand der das hat
Oder de facto de facto Standards wie OWASP Top 10
Okay ich bin absoluter Security Noob ich habe keine Ahnung was OWASP Top 10 ist
Achso ja das ergibt Sinn was die schreiben
Ich wusste aber nicht dass das OWASP Top 10 sind
Ja das stimmt ganz ja ja also das ist vollkommen logisch was die also
Sinnig was die schreiben aber ich wusste nicht dass es dass es OWASP Top 10 ist
Man merkt du bist lange im gleichen Job vieles neue Zeugs kennst du nicht
Kennst du das wusstest du was OWASP Top 10 ist und ISO 2700x
Natürlich weiß der Chat sagt jetzt natürlich immer so
Auf so eine Weise hat Chat immer klar wusste ich
Das hat man in der Schule schon gelernt
Der Grundschule hat man im Kindergarten habe ich das schon gelernt
Im Krankenhaus dem ich auf die Welt gekommen bin muss man das wissen
Okay das ist aber doch recht normal was da steht
Change
Was
Ach Chancengeber das ist das Problem
Wenn so viele Stellen anzeigen Basswörter gespickt Deutsch Englisch gemischt sind
Dann liest du manche Wörter nicht mehr richtig
Chancengeber
Okay ja gut es ist sinnvoll zwei Tage
Man braucht ja in den meisten Firmen brauchst ja schon zwei Tage bis da
Notebook und Account überhaupt funktioniert
Du kannst die ersten zwei Tage doch eh nichts machen
Das ist gut
Das sollten alle dabei schreiben wo das so ist weil das ist für mich ein riesen Vorteil
Dass man nicht irgendwelche fertigen Windows Setups nutzen muss oder sowas
Events mit Spaß Faktor Hemden und Plusen Reinigung
Okay cool für Leute die das brauchen Sportförderung Mitarbeiterprämien
Das wollten die übrigens bei uns bei mir auf der Arbeit wollten sie das auch mal anbieten
Hemden also nicht nur Hemden und Plusen die wollten Wäschereinigung quasi anbieten
Und das haben sie danach lange mit diskutieren hin und her gemacht
Nur das Problem war dass es teurer war als bei dem Reinigungs Dienstleister schräg gegenüber
Was natürlich im Endeffekt keiner nutzt jetzt
Hätten sie gesagt Hey für 10 Hemden oder so im Jahr
Nee im Jahr reicht nicht für 10 Hemden im Quartal kostenlos oder so wäre was anderes gewesen
Auszeit Raum für deine persönliche Lebensplanung okay
Also was gibt es Yes ich bin immer interessiert in was für Geld gibt
Kann man Filter nach wo wo Gehaltsdinger drin stehen
Nee kein Sellerie
Das wäre doch cool oder dass er einfach mal nach allen Filtern kann wo auch Gehaltsangaben drin stehen
Und wir gucken mal was es im Osten gibt easy schauen wir mal
Dresden in Saxony
Nö
In the Hood
Wie so ein Linux Administrator
Max bin Recruiter ich sag dir bei einem Jobwechsel in deinem Bereich locker 15k mehr
Ja
Glaube ich dir sofort
Ich habe ja vor zwei Jahren oder so war das mal
Oder vor drei vor zwei drei ich weiß
Nee ich glaube vor drei Jahren ist schon ein bisschen her
Ich hab ja mal sogar ein paar mich bei ein paar beworben und mit ein paar gelabert
Als mir auf der Arbeit so auf den Sack ging
Glaube ich dir sofort ja
Aber ich will nicht wechseln
Bei mir ist es nämlich mittlerweile so
Dass ich mittlerweile durch diese ganze Streaming und YouTube Geschichte
Nennt man es mal Ausgleich habe dass das eigentlich so 50 50 ist also
Ich gehe arbeiten aber wenn ich von der Arbeit komme mache ich mir keine Gedanken mehr drüber
Und dementsprechend will ich jetzt auch wenig Aufwand rein stecken so nach dem Motto
Neuen Job suchen irgendwas in der Richtung aus dem finde ich sogar ganz gut wo ich bin
Und deswegen habe ich da keine Ambition
Ja aber das gebe ich dir recht weiß ja nicht ob das Gebate war aber das deckt sich mit meinen Erfahrungen
Was ich da vor zwei Jahren oder zweieinhalb drei Jahren gemacht habe
Solange du glücklich bist ist die Hauptsache
Ich bin glücklich wenn der Chat glücklich ist
Ich weiß gar nicht ob ich schon erwähnt habe
Dass man sein Amazon account kostenlos mit Twitch verknüpfen kann
Und man einem Streamer seiner Wahl kostenlos ein Sub geben kann
Nein aber das war schon zumindest teilweise ernst gemeint Chat
Danke schön für den Sub
Äh wen haben wir denn hier
Blackmind21 exquisite
Massive IQ Steigerung für den Chat wieder
Und Real Cards auch Dankeschön Prime Subscription
Dankeschön für die Subs
So also was wollen sie denn hier Cloud Engineer in Dresden
Wir glauben daran dass die Zukunft den
Ich muss übrigens gerade mal schnell schauen ob ich euch Subs übersehen habe sogar
Boiner14 hatte ich glaube ich schon aber trotzdem noch Dankeschön
Oh das Scam Train ist am Start Leute hätte ich nichts gesagt
Der Gebate Train ist am Start
Durti Hari abonniert
Massive Sub
Aber ist auch ein Ding wie Elastic Surge
Deswegen wusste ich auch was der Elkstack ist
Der Elkstack
Elastic Surge, Lockstash, Kibana
Warum Scam Train einfach nur so
Weil euch Twitch letztendlich jebaiten will zum Suppen
Was ich ja gut finde weil dann verdiene ich was
Und Twitch findet das auch gut weil sie verdienen auch was dran
Der einzige der nichts daran verdient ist das Subscriber
Aber der kriegt Stream Content und Emotes
Außer bei mir da verdient der Subscriber auch IQ Points
Können wir mal wetten mit Kicks Points
Ja das habe ich mir schon überlegt ob wir das machen
Die Sache ist ich weiß nicht worauf man wetten soll
Aber die neuen Emotes sind auch wirklich cool oder
Ich muss dazu geben
Also Wupp Pock ist wirklich nice
Die Kicks konnte in IQ umwandeln
Dann ist man ja ganz schnell bei 250.000 IQ oder so
Random Org wetten ist doch
Hat die Bank bei der du arbeitest ein Plaus Symbol
Das wenn ich dir das jetzt sage ist relativ klar was es ist oder
Elk verkaufen wir jetzt an unsere Kunden um an Arbeit
G-Belt ist nicht benötig um unsere Schul
Big Brain Logik
Alter was ist denn jetzt los jetzt mit Zappt ohne Ende
Dankeschön Leute was ist denn hier los
Der CLI Jumper
Ich vermute mal dass der CLI Jumper ist weil der
Kommandozeilen Hacker am Start ist
Und ich vermute einfach mal dass es nicht der Klee Jumper ist
Danke schon für den Zappt dann haben wir noch Prime 1996
Dazu muss ich eigentlich schon mal E-Mode abspielen
The Penetrator X HD
Nee HDX
Danke schön für den Zappt
Nee das sag ich wahrscheinlich
An was hast du denn MX300 angeschlossen
An so einen günstigen Behringer Mischpult
Und dann an meinen Moto Audio Interface
Ja aber das ist schon ganz schön fail
Ist bei uns aber nicht viel anders
Wir haben das auch am Start
Niemand hat eine Ahnung
Vor allem mit Kaban Integration in Kibana und solche Dinger
Und der Elastic Search Cluster
Vielleicht muss ich jetzt mal kurz erzählen was der Elastic Search Cluster ist
Wir haben zwei Elastic Search Cluster
Wir haben einmal einen Elastic Search Cluster für Logs
Und Audit Geschichten
Und wir haben einen Elastic Search Cluster für das Außendienst System
Und für Volltext Suche
Und der Witz ist bei uns
So wirklich gut auskennt tut sich damit auch keiner
Und die Elastic Search Cluster machen öfters mal Probleme
Und die machen dann so komische Probleme
Dass zum Beispiel ein Elastic Search Cluster Note der Meinung ist
Er geht nicht mehr in den Cluster rein und sowas
Und das läuft darauf raus, dass wir alle paar Wochen irgendwelche
Calls, Tickets beim Elastic Search Support aufmachen müssen
Und der Elastic Search Support sagt dann
Sie haben auch keine Ahnung
Das lohnt sich immer diesen Support zu kaufen dann
Kostet ihr eins, zwei Monate?
Bist du nicht schon viel länger dabei?
Du bist auf jeden Fall schon oft im Stream, danke für den Sub
Nö
Hab ich nicht
Hatte die Bank was mit Wirecard zu tun?
Ich erzähl euch da nichts weiter zu
Jetzt überleg mal, hättet ihr was mit zu tun gehabt
Würde ich es bestimmt nicht sagen, oder?
Oder mich da irgendwie reinreiten
So, also schauen wir nochmal schnell weiter
So, das war nicht so spannend
Das sah ziemlich nur an 15 aus
Ach ne, das ist das in Dresden
Also was wollen die denn?
Dazu bringen wir auf der ganzen Welt Top-Unternehmen
Ok, das ist das Personalverschacherungs-Ding
Gibt es eigentlich nur noch Personalvermittler?
Ich habe das Gefühl die Hälfte der Anzeigen sind irgendwelche
Personalvermittler beziehungsweise Talentscouts
So lacht der Motto, ja?
Das ist doch nicht normal
Dass da keine richtige Stelle dahinter hängt
Erkennt man auch schon, weil das so generic ist alles
Was sucht denn SAP?
Da können wir echt mal gucken
Die suchen ein Cloud Infrastructure Automation Engineer
IT Architecture Senior Specialist
Wow
Ok, blablabla
Also, Remote Work, Flexible Work Schedule
Ok, klingt schon mal in der aktuellen Zeit gut
Also man wird sich erfreuen an einem guten Work-Life-Balance
An einer gesunden Work-Life-Balance
Und man gehört zu einer diversen Workspace-Culture
Ich nehme die mich überhaupt
Ich bin ja nicht nur weiß und männlich
Ich bin auch noch alt
Und nicht vegan
Und auch nicht schwul oder so
Ich bin da glaube ich nicht divers genug für
Und Trump-Fehler
Trump hätte ich wahrscheinlich nicht gewählt
Auch wenn ich in den USA wählen könnte
Da hätte ich das gleiche Problem gehabt wie bei uns
Ich wüsste nicht was ich wählen soll
Weil ich beide total scheiße fand
So als Noob außenstehender
Das gleiche Problem habe ich ja bei uns auch
Ich weiß auch nicht wen ich wählen soll
Aber ich glaube ich werde diesmal nicht ungültig wählen
Ich habe in den letzten Wahlen immer ungültig gewählt
Außer bei der letzten oder vorletzten Europawahl
Wo ich mich total verirrt habe und die Grünen gewählt habe
Ich weiß auch nicht so genau warum
Das fand ich im Nachhinein gar nicht so sinnvoll
Aber ernsthaft ich tendiere aktuell zur FDP
Es ist alles irgendwie schwachsinnig
Und ich glaube nicht dass irgendwie einer wirklich guten Zukunftsplan hat
Aber die erscheinen mir bei manchen Sachen noch am
Wie soll ich sagen so am
Am nächsten dran an der Realität
Die Partei
Ich habe letztens Wahlromat gemacht
Und da kam raus ich soll die Partei wählen
Und auf den zweiten Punkt die AfD
Das heißt ich habe jetzt die Auswahl zwischen AfD und Satire
Exzellent
Ja aber es dauert noch
Es ist doch wann ist es Oktober oder so
September
Ich meine da sieht man doch mal wie verzweifelt ich sein muss ja
Es passt ja überhaupt nicht zusammen
Bei dem letzten Europa Ding die Grünen gewählt
Sonst immer ungültig weil mir alles auf den Sack geht
Jetzt überlegen ob ich nicht die FDP wähle
Aber der Wahlromat sagt mir ich soll Satire oder AfD wählen
Also was denn jetzt
Da gibt es überhaupt keinen Sinn
Ich wähle einfach die Tierschutzpartei oder sowas
Das ist wenigstens was was ich für wichtig erachte
Die Tierschutzpartei
Scheiß auf Wahlromat
Doch wir machen wir machen im September wieder den Wahlromat
Wir machen im September wieder Wahlromat
Dann können wir gucken was da rauskommt
Ok das sieht jetzt auch relativ normal aus
Also ich muss sagen
Oh SAP hat das Diversity Commitment
Ist ja nichts Schlimmes dran
Auch wenn ich mich manchmal ein bisschen lustig mache wie sie sich teilweise übelst Mühe geben
Das über korrekt zu schreiben immer alles
An sich finde ich ist das ja eine gute Sache
Also ich finde es gut
Wenn man Leute auch eine Chance gibt wo man vielleicht früher gesagt hätte alter ne da kommt uns nicht ins Haus
Das finde ich prinzipiell nicht verkehrt
Man muss es halt nicht krampfhaft machen ja
Also ich bin ich bin eigentlich unterm Strich der Meinung man sollte den besten einstellen für den Job
Also sprich
Wenn du fünf Bewerber hast
Was weiß ich
Ein weißen Mann
Dabei ist der halt am besten qualifiziert ist
Dann sollte man halt den weißen Mann einstellen
Wenn am besten für den Job geeignet ist
Oder umgedreht wenn das nicht ist dann halt nicht
Und wenn der asiatische Frau am besten für geeignet ist dann soll man die einstellen
Oder eigentlich keine Ahnung ein diverser Inder soll man den einstellen
Ich glaube auch nicht ich glaube auch nicht dass Quoten wirklich was bringen
Sie hatten jetzt in Frankreich Probleme habe ich gelesen
Dass das
Ich glaube in Paris dass die Stadtverwaltung in Paris
Zu viele Frauen hat
Und dass deswegen nicht
Divers genug ist
Also es geht auch in die andere Richtung
Normalerweise hört man es ja immer umgedreht
Und muss ich sagen vollkommen okay
Das ist das was ich unter Gleichberechtigung verstehe
Man sollte allen die gleichen Chancen geben
Und dementsprechend aber auch die gleichen Pflichten
Also wenn einer die Möglichkeit hat das zu machen
Dann sollte er auch die gleichen Pflichtungen zu haben
Und wenn es die Regelung gibt 50% so 50% so
Dann bedeutet das nicht 70% Männer und es bedeutet auch nicht 70% Frauen
Sondern es heißt 50 50
Also da muss man müssen sich doch alle Seiten dran halten
Das ist eigentlich ganz einfach ja
Ich finde wir sollten allgemein bisschen weniger Wind um dieses Thema machen
Und letztendlich bei jedem entscheidet man sollte jedem die Möglichkeit geben das zu machen was er will
Aber man sollte niemand dazu hinträngen ja
Wenn du wenn du wenn 90% der Mädels eben keinen Informatik studieren wollen oder so
Dann ist das doch okay
Wenn sie nicht wollen ist es in Ordnung
Ich sehe überhaupt nicht ein warum man das quasi dann forcieren müsste irgendwie
Wenn man nicht will ist es okay
Es gab doch es gab letztens eine Konferenz
Und da haben sie es auch total übertrieben meiner Meinung nach
Es war eine PHP Konferenz
Und es haben sich ein paar Leute unter anderem so die Headline Speaker
Also quasi die mit denen geworben wurde für diese Konferenz
Die haben sich teilweise daran gestört dass es keine Frauen auf der Konferenz gab
Ist ja mal ein Punkt wo man darüber diskutieren muss warum das nicht so ist
Und jetzt haben die dann gesagt ey wir geben Teile unserer Redezeit ab
Dass der Veranstalter quasi noch Frauen in diese offenen Speaker Slots packen kann
Und dann hat der Veranstalter gesagt nein das macht er nicht
Weil er wirbt damit dass das halt das sind halt die Aushängeschilder für diese Konferenz
Und außerdem hat sich keine Frau beworben für einen Talk
Und er sieht es nicht ein warum man das jetzt übers Knie brechen müsste
Nur weil das dem ein oder anderen nicht gefällt
Ich finde da hat er als Veranstalter auch das Recht dazu das zu sagen hey ich habe das so geplant
Das passt ihr habt euch dafür beworben das passt ihr kriegt Geld dafür dass ihr die Headline Speaker seid
Und da haben die so einen riesen Ack gemacht
Dass er die Konferenz am Ende absagen musste
Das finde ich total idiotisch sowas die müssen sich alle mal wieder auf normales Level runterfahren
Das X-Feltel da gäbe ich dir recht
Wenn du als Frau in der IT bist musst du dir sicherlich viel Mist anhören
Aber selbst wenn das nicht so wäre hättest du trotzdem nicht den halben Jahrgang Mädchen im Informatik Studiengang
Es gab hier schon genug Tests dazu und umso weniger man das beeinflusst hat
Umso weniger man Einfluss darauf genommen hat für was sich die Leute entscheiden
Umso stärker haben sich tatsächlich traditionelle Rollenbilder gezeigt
Also sprich Frauen haben sich mehr für Soziales und sowas in der Richtung entschieden
Und Männer mehr für Technik
Also ich finde man sollte da keinen zu zwingen
Ja ich finde das nicht gut wenn Frauen sich das nicht trauen zu machen obwohl sie wollen
Aber selbst wenn das nicht so wäre du wirst keine 50-50 überall haben
Dafür liegen die Interessen im Durchschnitt einfach nicht so
Ja und deswegen finde ich sie sollten sich alle mal ein bisschen runterfahren
Und eine Sache finde ich was auch immer ein bisschen vernachlässigt wird ist
Wie gesagt ich finde alles gut
Aber wir reden beim Thema wenn man sowas wie Gleichberechtigung sagt
Dann bedeutet das ja natürlich dass man die gleichen Rechte hat aber dementsprechend auch die gleichen Verpflichtungen hat
Das muss natürlich auch sein
Und sofern das alle akzeptieren können ist doch vollkommen in Ordnung ist doch top
Lasst die Leute einfach machen was sie wollen
Es sollte mal jeder ein bisschen tolerant sein
Und gerade die die immer er meinen sie sind so super tolerant das sind eigentlich meistens die schlimmsten im Intoleranz sein
Ja oft doch da habe ich dir recht es gibt sicherlich Bereiche da ist das nicht verkehrt mit Quoten
Dort wo es quasi so etabliert ist wo du sagen wir mal gar keine Chance hast das irgendwie aufzubrechen
Aber auf der anderen Seite eine Sache darf man auch nicht vergessen
Rein aus wie gesagt ich weiß dass es nicht so ist nicht so ist aber rein aus rein wirtschaftlicher Sicht
Wenn ich jetzt Arbeitgeber wäre
Und ich würde von vorne rein sagen
Ich will keine Männer einstellen ich will keine Frauen einstellen oder sonst was
Da wäre ich ja blöd wenn ich das machen würde
Weil ich mir damit eventuell die besten Kandidaten raube
Also ich bekomme schlechtere Kandidaten als meine Konkurrenz
Also rein schon aus dem Gesichtspunkt ist es eigentlich doof das zu machen
Klar es gibt immer noch genug Leute die haben andere Beweggründe das zu machen
Aber rein aus wirtschaftlicher Sicht ist es doof das zu machen
Warum soll ich einem anderen die besseren Kandidaten überlassen anstatt mir aus irgendwelchen Dingern nicht selbst zu nehmen
Was ich auch witzig fand es gab ja mal so ein Café
Ich glaube wo war denn das
Das könnte ja in den USA gewesen sein
Die hatten so ein Café wo Männer quasi steuern bezahlen mussten
Also sprich Männer die in diesem Café was getrunken haben mussten mehr Geld bezahlen als Frauen
So Privilege Text oder irgendwie sowas
Und dann haben die sich ernsthaft gewundert
Dass sie nach frag mich nicht eineinhalb Jahren dicht machen mussten weil es sich nicht gelohnt hat
Ja also das hätten wir sich doch von Anfang an denken können
Und ist das nicht gleichermaßen diskriminierend wenn du sagst Männer bezahlen mal 30% mehr
Hättest du das mal umgedreht gemacht da wäre der Aufschrei riesengroß gewesen
Ach ich verstehs nicht wie gesagt ich bin der Meinung die sollten sich alle mal ein bisschen runterfahren
Und nicht in allem gleich den Teufel vermuten vielleicht auch mal vielleicht auch mal
Leuten 5 Minuten zuhören die die Sachen nicht 100% nicht so sehen wie sie selber
Das wäre eh ne coole Sache wenn wir das mal wieder hinkriegen würden hier
Weil unabhängig davon ob links rechts oben unten oder auf dem Kopf
Das was die Gesellschaft spaltet was man so gerade diskutiert
Sind eigentlich intolerante Leute auf beiden Seiten
Es ist vollkommen egal wer das ist aber umso mehr diese Kultur nicht
Also umso weniger du das praktizierst dass du miteinander redest
Umso festgefahrener wird das ganze
So das ist eigentlich so ein bisschen das Problem
Es gibt so viele Themen da kannst du öffentlich nicht drüber reden
Ohne dass du von irgendeiner Seite gesteinigt wird
Gesteinigt wirst es ist egal ob es Flüchtlinge sind ob es Corona ist
Ob es Frauenquote ist oder sonst was das sind alles Themen
Die sind akut die sind wichtig aber die sind so aufgeladen
Dass die meisten Leute sich nicht trauen öffentlich drüber zu reden
Weil sie entweder wie gesagt sinnbildlich gesteinigt werden dafür
Von einem der Seiten oder mit Eier beworfen werden ja
Das ist echt problematisch finde ich auch nicht gut
Denn wir reden nicht unbedingt vom Twittermob
Es ist privat in Familien auch schon so
Du kriegst so viele Business an Frauenquote geht so geht so vielleicht
Also wenn du die China die China Dinge und random Sachen mit
Mit zählst du zwei oder so am Tag zwei drei
Aber da zähl ich jetzt auch Raid Shadow Legends und so ein Mist dabei
Ja aber es ist doch privat in den Familien auch schon so
Wenn du da bisschen größere Familie hast
Da hast du zwangsläufig Leute die halt so diese kritischen Themen
Vielleicht nicht alle gleich sehen so und da geht es ab
Die Leute können auch nicht normal drüber reden
Man kann es doch man kann es doch durchaus akzeptieren wenn einer
Was anders sieht er ist doch deswegen jetzt nicht gleich der Teufel so
Mach mal Raid Shadow Legends Werbung ich habe schon überlegt die bezahlen
Ganz schön viel Geld die bezahlen bis zu was an bis zu 1300 Euro für
So ein Popel so klein ist das Stream mittlerweile auch nicht mehr
Aber die haben sie nämlich alle was die bezahlen
Aber ganz davon abgesehen will ich das nicht machen weil das absoluter Crap ist
Toleranz gegenüber Intoleranz Ja das kann man in beide Seiten drehen
Das kann man in beide Seiten das kann man in beide Seiten drehen
Ich habe das früher auch mal gesagt Toleranz gegenüber Intoleranz
Aber das Problem ist das kannst du in beide Seiten drehen
Also das kannst du so drehen so nach dem Motto wie
Du musst alles akzeptieren oder du kannst auch rumdrehen mit
Du musst nichts mehr akzeptieren also der Satz ergibt eigentlich keinen Sinn
Deswegen finde ich den nicht mal gut das ist sowas habe ich früher selbst gesagt
Finde ich jetzt aber nicht mehr ganz so sinnvoll
Kann man denn mit ein komplettes Setup nachsehen
Nee habe ich nichts
Gab es denn nicht für Montenden ein Hard Placement während des Streams 50k als Angebot
Klar kann schon sein die Typen haben ja anscheinend übelst Kohle
Raid Shadow Legends wo kommen die eigentlich her
Raid Shadow Legends wo was für einen Anbieter ist das
Plarium KS Unity wundert mich nicht
Wo kommen die her
Fakt die haben dann Forum
Israeli okay ich hätte jetzt eigentlich gedacht dass das irgendwelche Chinesen oder so sind
Ich hätte gedacht das ist Frami Tencent oder sowas
Raid Shadow Legends
Als ob die Impressoren hast du doch gesehen
Ja Amador hast du recht
Das ist auch sowas das ist das letzte was ich dazu sage er hat hier geschrieben
Danach ist Danach ist auch gut mit Lage zum der Nation
Ja vor allem ist es manchmal völlig weltfremd und wirtschaftlich absolut nicht umsetzbar was der Leute vor den ja also
Ich bin ja immer dafür dass man Visionen hat das ist das so mein Problem warum ich nicht war also
Eines der Problem warum ich nicht genau weiß wen ich wählen soll weil ich keinen da irgendwie mit großartiger Visionen sehe
Der mir wirklich sinnvoll sagen kann Hey Max so stelle ich mir die Zukunft vor und das ist der Weg wie wir dahin kommen
Also ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen weltfremd zu sein in Ideen und so finde ich gar nicht verkehrt
Aber es hat ja keinen Sinn wenn man
So wie soll ich das jetzt sagen also
Wenn man sich unschaffbare Dinge ausdenkt ohne einen Plan zu haben wie man es machen will
Das ist so wie wenn das ist das ist wenn wenn dann jemand sich hinstellt und sagt bis 2075 haben wir das und das
Vor allem ohne jeglichen Plan dabei wie man das haben will
Internet hier Kohleausstieg bis dann dann wo Internetausbau bis 2000 irgendwie da
Ja das ist manchmal echt völlig weltfremd vor allem halt mit null Plan wie man wie man dahin kommt ja
Und das nächste das nächste ist auch ein punkt man muss auch gucken dass man langfristig irgendwie den Wohlstand der Bevölkerung sichert
Es hat doch keinen Sinn wenn man sich um Gott und die Welt und alles mögliche Gedanken macht
Aber immer mehr Leute arm sind die überhaupt nichts davon haben und es ist nun mal so
Dass die Schere zwischen Arm und Reich so weit auseinander gegangen ist mir noch nie vor und dass immer mehr Leute arm sind auch in Deutschland und gerade wo immer gesagt wird es haben alle so viel Kohle und sonst was
Guckt euch den Pfandflaschen Sammeloper am Hauptbahnhof an
Ob der nur so viel Geld hat wage ich zu bezweifeln ja
Das hat das hat wie gesagt teilweise echt kein kein Hand und Fuß
Und es ist jetzt nicht nur der Pfandflaschen Sammeloper am Hauptbahnhof sind ganz viele Leute die man jeden Tag sieht von denen man das gar nicht weiß von dem man es vielleicht gar nicht denkt die aber
Nicht arm im Sinne von Arm so wie man sich das in Afrika vorstellen muss sind
Aber gemessen an dem Standard hier und im Vergleich zu dem was andere haben auch im Durchschnitt Arm sind es gibt ja diese diese Statistik
Ich glaube ich letztens hatten sie beim Spiegel da was ganz gutes zu es gibt ja diese Statistik wo sie gucken hey nicht Durchschnitt also nicht was hat theoretisch der Durchschnittsdeutsche also das bezieht ja auch die ein die
Ultra reich sind das heißt der Durchschnitt sieht gar nicht so schlecht aus sondern dieses ganze bereinigte so und das sieht sehr spannend aus nämlich das ist
Guck ob ich das finde
Armuts Grenze
Die hatten so was richtig schönes mit mit Graf wo man drin rumklicken konnte
Das meine ich nicht zumindest hat man da gesehen dass das mit wir haben so viel geld absolut nicht stimmt
Ich finde es jetzt nicht mehr ist ist auch wurscht
Zumindest so diese Aussage wir haben so viel Geld ist nicht so wir haben im Durchschnitt vielleicht viel Geld weil man die allerreichsten Mitarbeit zählt über die ganze Bevölkerung und dann im Durchschnitt
Aber wenn man guckt was die Leute in der Tasche haben dann ist das eben nicht viel wenn man mal so die allerärmsten und die allerreichsten paar Prozent weglässt dann sieht man das dann nicht so viel übrig bleibt zumal man auch nicht vergessen darf dass viele Leute vielleicht jetzt nicht
Arm sind in Form von auf der Straße leben oder oder nicht zu essen haben oder sowas in der Richtung aber die quasi komplett arbeiten gehen 40 Stunden die Woche und sich davon nichts leisten können und dass sie sich nicht mal die Chance haben irgendeine Art von Vermögen anzusparen weil die einfach von Monatsgehalt zu Monatsgehalt leben
Das ist auch scheiße überlegt euch mal ihr geht 40 Stunden die Woche arbeiten nur dass ihr am Ende des Monats minus 200 Euro auf dem Konto habt was auch für ein Arsch ist
Ja und ich finde das sind so Dinge über die man sich echt mal auch auch öffentlich Diskussionen sich mal Gedanken machen muss. Ach was bei der VATS war es gerade beim Spiegel kann auch sein
Worum es geht wir haben uns eigentlich heute Stellenanzeigen angeguckt aber ich bin irgendwie abgeschweift. Ja das ist so ein bisschen das was ich gemeint habe an Statistik aber die hatten so einen coolen Graf wo man reinklicken konnte wo man das dann auch je nach Bundesland wo man das rumziehen konnte das war eigentlich ganz cool
Oh äh hallo gibt es da noch ein ordentliches Bild zu? Wo ist das Bild?
Ja
Moment das war was anderes oder? War das das? Ich habe immer das Problem wenn ich einen Artikel gelesen habe mit einer Grafik dabei dann sehe ich einen anderen Artikel mit einer anderen Grafik die was ähnliches sagen soll aber eine komplett unterschiedliche Grafik ist
Ah ok gut da siehst du dass wir einige haben die übelst viel Kohle haben
Naja
Gut ist auch jetzt ja habe ich dir jetzt genug darüber ausgelassen es hat im Prinzip eh keinen Sinn das ist auch das warum ich es mittlerweile schon aufgegeben habe äh es hat eh es ist eh vollkommen egal was ich dazu sage oder ihr dazu sagt
Wir können nicht damit rechnen dass irgendjemand sich in unserem Sinne einsetzt das seid ihr nicht habt Millionen und könnt irgendwie nice Lobbyarbeit machen deswegen fällt es mir noch schwerer mich zu entscheiden wie ich wählen soll
Letztendlich habe ich es aufgegeben dass sich irgendeiner für mich einsetzt
Ich bin doch nicht reich warum muss ich Spitzensteuersatz bezahlen das geht mir so auf den Keks
Das lag wahrscheinlich daran dass das wo ich noch jünger war war der ganze Kram noch deutlich höher ich verdiene ganz ok mit meinem Job ja ich verdiene noch ein bisschen was nebenbei aber ich habe keinen goldenen BMW in der ähm ja ich bezahle mehr Steuern als Amazon aber ich habe keinen goldenen BMW in der Garage stehen oder sowas
Ich habe vergessen ab wann Spitzensteuersatz ist ich glaube Spitzensteuersatz ist was 42% und ab wann 56k 58k oder irgendwie sowas im Jahr
57 ja irgendwie ist doch der Witz das ist das ist doch wirklich der Witz du bist doch nicht du bist doch ab 7 und du bist doch nicht reich mit 57k
Ok ich meine das heißt ja auch sagt es ja auch nicht ja das sagt es ja auch nicht es heißt ja auch nicht es heißt ja auch nicht reichen Spitzensteuer oder so aber Spitzensteuersatz hört sich für mich so an ok das ist das oberste die oberste Ende und das sollten dementsprechend auch die Leute bezahlen die am obersten Ende verdienen
Aber ich meine 57k ich will nicht sagen das es in irgendeiner Art und Weise wenig ist das ist im Vergleich zu anderen wahrscheinlich sogar noch relativ viel aber ich betracht mich da nicht irgendwie als reich und ich sehe es nicht als Spitzensteuersatz zu bezahlen
Ja wenn ich jetzt meine Yacht in Mallorca hätte oder so na gut vielleicht verrate ich es euch ja auch nur nicht sie ist positiv alles was du mehr verdienst gehört mit 58% hier excellent
So und das ist auch der Grund warum ich komplett aufgegeben habe ja das ist das Problem das genau das ist ja eigentlich das Problem wenn man sich die aktuelle Statistik anguckt dann ist das nicht dann ist das nicht reich es ist aber gemessen an dem was im Durchschnitt verdient wird sehr viel was aber halt eigentlich der Witz ist reich ist aber was anderes
Das war übrigens noch vor 15 Jahren so war das deutlich höher
Ne ach genau und deswegen nachdem so viele Sachen die für mich relevant sind sei es Infrastrukturausbau öffentlicher Nahverkehr oder auch Sachen wie Tierschutz meinetwegen ja nachdem ich da nicht das Gefühl habe dass es irgendjemand gibt der sich wirklich für meine Interessen einsetzt
ist mir das halt mittlerweile alles ziemlich egal geworden
Also ich hab für mich jetzt so das Fazit gezogen ich kann nicht darauf hoffen dass sich irgendjemand mal in meinem Interesse einsetzt oder meine Interessen vertritt so sinnig dass dann auch was für mich rauskommt
Deswegen geht es mir eigentlich alles am Arsch vorbei mittlerweile
Das stimmt im Vergleich zu anderen Ländern ist das bei uns mit Tierschutz schon gar nicht so übel
Ja deswegen ist das einzige was man machen kann gucken dass man selbst seine Sachen ordentlich macht
Leider und deswegen muss sich auch keiner wundern wo sich immer die letzten Jahre drüber aufgeregt wird so nach dem Motto
Die Gesellschaft wird immer egoistischer ja warum wohl weil jeder mit der Zeit merkt dass keiner für ihn was macht
Das kommt eins zum anderen und ich meine es nicht dass der Nachbar der Oma die Tüte reinträgt
Also was bleibt den Leuten übrig zu gucken dass sie sich um ihren Scheiß selbst kümmern
Und so möglichst wie wenig davon abgeben auch so blöds klingt bleibt ja fast nichts anderes übrig
Du kannst dich nicht darauf verlassen dass irgendjemand mal einer Politik in deinem Sinne machen würde
Vielleicht stinkt das jetzt auch ein bisschen zu negativ aber ich sehe es nicht
Nutzt du weiterhin WhatsApp ich habe noch nie WhatsApp verwendet Keckweight
Bin ich viel zu faul für Lul ja so ist es so sieht es aus
Ja genau und deswegen ganz ehrlich es kann doch nicht angehen
Es kann doch nicht angehen dass so viele Leute verarscht werden in dieser Richtung das erste ist
Ich habe den Chat weggeklickt
Es kann doch nicht sein dass so viele Leute verarscht werden das erste ist
Wenn du 40 Stunden die Woche arbeiten gehst was sinnvolles machst eventuell sogar was wo die Allgemeinheit von profitiert
Kann es nicht sein dass du mit minus 200 Euro am Ende des Monats gerade so über die Runden kommst
Keine Chance hast du jemals irgendeine Art und Weise von Vermögen aufzubauen weil du quasi immer bei null bist am Ende des Monats
Das ist das erste was mir auf den Keks geht
Also natürlich natürlich kommt da auch noch mehr dazu es gibt auch Leute die maßlos über ihre Verhältnisse leben ja
Also das müsste nicht bei allen so sein bei vielen ist das sicherlich auch Haus gemacht ja
Aber anderen ist schlicht und ergreifend auch einfach zu wenig
Dass sie gar keine Chance haben irgendwie großartig was aufbauen zu können
Und das nächste ist was mir auch auf den Keks geht
Das nächste was mir auf den Keks geht und wo die Leute auch richtig verarscht werden jetzt wenn man sich mal die Berufe anguckt
Wo auch wirklich was für die Allgemeinheit gemacht wird
Dass sie immer mit irgendwelchem dummen Gelaber abgespeist werden guckt euch beispielsweise mal an
Anfang von Corona
Wo sie alle die Leute im Supermarkt gelobt haben
Und unsere Helden an der Supermarktkasse und wir sind euch so dankbar
Und dafür kann sich keiner was kaufen ja davon kann auch keiner seine Miete bezahlen
Einfach nur dummes Gelaber
Einfach nur dummes Gelaber nichts nichts bei rausgekommen
So das nächste ist den ganzen Krankenpflegern und Krankenschwestern
Den haben sie am Anfang von Corona auch erzählt
Unsere Helden und haben geklatscht vom Krankenhaus und alles
Und haben gesagt hier jetzt gibt es jetzt gibt es aber richtig was
Und ich habe damals im Stream noch so gesagt so halb aus Spaß
Eigentlich müssten die jetzt sagen es ist ja super
Dass ihr uns so dankbar seid und dass es jetzt hier mehr Geld gibt
Wir werden jetzt einfach nicht mehr arbeiten bis das unterschrieben ist
Es ist kannst du nicht machen da sterben Leute dran
Aber eigentlich hättest du es machen müssen weil klar war
Sobald die Sache nur ein bisschen besser gegangen ist wieder
Hat man diese Sachen mit Lohnerhöhung und mehr Geld gleich mal wieder vergessen
Gab es einfach nichts
Aber so hat sich jetzt erledigt
Das Problem ist nur gewesen dann kam jetzt Corona im Winter
Ja gut jetzt müssten sie doch mal gucken was da jetzt rauskommt
Mal gucken ob es wirklich ordentlich mehr Kohle gab
Mehr Kohle gibt ich bezweifle es ja vielleicht kriegen die wie gesagt eine Sonderzahlung
Paar hundert Euro
Das ist auch so eine Verteilung die ich nicht in Ordnung finde
Und da kann ich es verstehen wenn die Leute egoistischer werden
Weil die haben jetzt jahrelang erlebt es setzt sich niemand für sie ein
Was sollen die dann machen außer egoistischer werden
Die verarschen die Pflegeleute ja doppelt
Erstens mit ihrem Gehalt
Zweitens mit den ganzen Arbeitsbedingungen
Und drittens habe ich vergessen was ich sagen wollte
Und drittens dass sie die gegeneinander ausspielen können
Also sprich niemand der so einen sozialen Beruf macht
Und sich dafür auch eventuell entschieden hat
Weil er eben am Leben anderer Menschen interessiert ist
Niemand der das macht sagt
Ich nehme in Kauf das Leute sterben dass ich mehr Geld kriege
Das ist halt die Scheiße und das nutzen die auch klarenlos aus
Normalerweise müsstest du sagen so nach dem Motto
Ja morgen arbeiten wir nicht mehr bis ihr den Scheiß endlich unterschreibt
Eigentlich müsstest du das so machen dass du wirklich mehr Geld kriegst
Aber auf der anderen Seite gerade die Leute die so sozial sind in diesen Berufen arbeiten
Wollen das nicht und können das nicht übers Herz bringen was ich auch voll ganz verstehen kann ja
Was dann für ein Arsch ist
Die werden von allen Seiten komplett jebaited
Das sind eigentlich Probleme wo man sich echt mal Gedanken drüber machen muss
Wo man sich auch mal Gedanken drüber machen muss
Ich weiß ich laber jetzt schon lange rum aber stream ist eh spätestens 2h schon vorbei
Wo man sich auch mal Gedanken drüber machen muss ist
Was macht man mit den ganzen Leuten die durch Technik und neue Sachen ihre Arbeit verlieren
Ich mein du kannst doch nicht
Ich pick mir jetzt mal eine Sache raus ja
Du kannst keinen Berger weiter zum Programmierer umschulen
Ausnahme besteht in die Regel das wird bestimmt bei einigen funktionieren aber bei den meisten wahrscheinlich nicht
Also das klappt schon mal nicht
Hat dafür irgendjemanden einen Plan was sie machen wollen
Ich mein es wird ja immer mehr
Vielleicht für Kobol ja
Ja frage ich mich echt hat da hat da irgendeiner hat da irgendeiner nen sinnvollen so parteien mich so einen sinnvollen Plan für
Don't cry so much
Ja das vermisse ich bei vielen Leuten auch
Die da gebe ich dir insofern recht was mich da auch immer ankotzt ist
Die Leute denken mittlerweile nur noch in links rechts oben runden schwarz weiß
Also sprich heute ist es so habe ich zumindest den Eindruck dass keiner mehr
Ein Text liest und sich die Aussage dahinter anguckt
Sondern er liest den Text schon mit der Erwartung
Das ist linksgrün versiffter gutmensch oder das ist rechter nazi
Mit diesem
Ding im Hinterkopf lesen die das schon und sind schon gleich auf 180
Das ist eigentlich das Problem
Gut manche können auch nicht lesen das gibt es natürlich auch
Die suchen danach die suchen in allem was rassistisches
Was oder was auch immer so ihre Weltanschauung widerspricht um dann drauf zu springen
Alle seiten
Deswegen sag ich ich habe
Der Dalai Lama das ist der einzige dem ich auf Twitter folge der irgendwas mit Religion zu tun hat
Weil ich finde der erzählt durchaus sinnvolle Sachen
Von dem könnten sich gut er ist ja auch erleuchtet
Ja oder oder kurz vorm erleuchtet sein oder was auch immer
Aber von dem könnten sich echt alle Seiten mal was abschneiden
Die sollen sich alle mal beruhigen
Ja und mal ein bisschen wie soll man das auf Deutsch nennen
Nächstenliebe ist das falsche Wort
Ein bisschen ein Fühl vermögen und ein bisschen
Offenheit für andere Meinung entwickeln ja
Das das wäre das wäre ganz nice
Max ist Buddhist
Also von allen jetzt mal ohne Mist ich bin absolut nicht religiös das wisst ihr
Ich bin mal getauft worden
Ja das ist alles und ich war auch mal im Kommunionsunterricht
Und wir haben die Kommunionsunterricht Lehrerin komplett in den Wahnsinn getrieben
Das weiß ich noch weil wir über die Tische gerannt sind und sonst was gemacht haben
Aber von allen Religionen die wir so haben
Da wären wir das ganze buddhistische und wir meditieren mal eine Runde vor uns hin
Mit Abstand das liebste sage ich euch
Das ist das womit ich mich echt noch am ehesten identifizieren kann
Auch wenn ich mit erleuchtet sein und irgendwelchen Götter hier und sonstwo echt nichts anfangen kann
Aber die Aussagen nach hinten finde ich gar nicht mal so verkehrt
Zumindest was der Dalai Lama so von sich abgibt ja
Und von dem könnten sich echt viele mal eine Scheibe abschneiden
Wusstet ihr eigentlich wo wir gerade beim Thema sind
Dass die Leute überall was rassistisches suchen
Wusstet ihr eigentlich dass der Dalai Lama sogar rassistisch ist
Wo wir gerade beim Thema sind dass sich so viele Leute immer was suchen
Worüber sie sich aufregen können
Wusstet ihr dass der Dalai Lama rassistisch ist
So und wisst ihr auch warum
Das sage ich nicht ich das wurde dem Dalai Lama vorgeworfen
Nee Sexist, sorry nicht rassist, Sexist
Der Dalai Lama ist angeblich sexistisch weil
Man muss sagen Englisch ist ja auch nicht seine Muttersprache
Und der drückt das vielleicht nicht alles 100%ig top aus
Aber man versteht immer was er meint ja
Zumindest er hat in einem Interview gesagt
So nach dem Motto ich glaube sie haben ihn gefragt
Was würde er sich für sein nächstes Leben wünschen
Das ist ja so eine typische buddhistische Frage
Und da hat der Dalai Lama darauf geantwortet
Er hofft dass er vielleicht als hübsche Frau geboren wird
Und jetzt muss man den Satz noch weiter noch weiter noch weiter sagen
Dass ihm mehr Leute zuhören
So also ey eigentlich eine Aussage die überhaupt nicht schlimm ist
Das sind die eskaliert wieder
Das sind die durchgedreht haben sich aufgeregt allesamt wieder
Da habe ich mir auch gedacht ihr dreht
Ich meine hallo wenn es eine Person auf dieser Welt gibt
Von dem ich nicht vermuten würde dass er rassistisch sexistisch
Oder irgendwas überhaupt Menschen verachten das ist
Dann ist es der Dalai Lama
Ich hab keine Ahnung wie die Leute darauf kommen jetzt
Und da wollten sie dass er sich entschuldigt und sonst was
Dabei haben sie sich wieder nur die halbe Aussage angehört
Die haben nur sich angehört
Er wünscht sich als Frau
Was ist daran eigentlich so schlimm wenn man sagt ich möchte als Frau auf die Welt kommen
Ich meine in der heutigen Zeit ist es nur wirklich kein Ding mehr
Auf der anderen Seite wäre das doch gut
Stellt euch mal vor der Dalai Lama wäre eine Frau
Dann wäre eine der größten
Wie heißt das so
Glaubensvorsitzende Typen weiblich
Das müsste doch eigentlich top in die aktuelle Zeit passen
Also wie man sich da drüber aufregen kann
Aber man kann sich über alles aufregen
Mein Lieblingsbeispiel für sinnlose Aufreger ist als
Ich weiß nicht wer von euch Overwatch gespielt hat
Kennt jemand den London Comic Overwatch
Wo Tracer am Start ist und man gesehen hat dass Tracer eine Freundin hat
Also quasi in dem Comic wurde gesagt Tracer ist lesbisch
So und da habe ich mir damals gesagt okay Tracer ist ja quasi so das Aushängeschild von Overwatch
Also der Charakter hier der da
Und dort wurde dann gesagt okay die hat eine Freundin
Und da habe ich mir gesagt okay Blizzard
Ich meine das ist das Aushängeschild von dem Spiel
Ist ja eigentlich da kann doch jetzt keiner was dagegen haben oder
Also ich habe mir damals wirklich gesagt da kann man doch jetzt nichts dagegen sagen
Aber doch genau die Leute die sich drüber aufgeregt haben
Dass der Overwatch Cast nicht divers genug ist
Haben sich drüber aufgeregt dass es Tracer ist
Weil Tracer ist ein Charakter der explizit für das männliche Auge entworfen wurde
Was für eine Scheiße kann man sich denn noch alles zusammenreiben alter
So was bescheuertes
Ich fand das gut das Blizzard gesagt hat
Das Aushängeschild so quasi so der
Frontcharakter Aushängeschildcharakter
Was die quasi loremäßig gesagt haben die ist lesbisch
Das fand ich eigentlich halt passt super in die heutige Zeit
War eine richtig coole Geschichte aber das genau die Leute die sonst für sowas sind
Sich dann noch drüber beschwert haben
Was hätten sie denn noch um sich Saria oder was
Stellt euch mal vor die hätten nicht Tracer genommen sondern hätten Saria aus Overwatch genommen
Dann hätten sie gesagt oha
Dicke russische Bodybuilder Lesbo geht ja auch gar nicht
Hätten sich auch drüber aufgeregt
Ja was denn jetzt
Ja was das ergibt doch überhaupt keinen Sinn
Es ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn
Die Leute suchen einfach nur was über das sie sich aufregen können
Da geht es überhaupt nicht drum irgendwas
Sinnvolles zu machen einfach nur sich aufzuregen
Richtig hängen geblieben alles richtig hängen geblieben
Ja Blockwatcher leider die Chinesen haben es ja mit dem Dalai Lama nicht so
Ja also
Ja und dann hast du halt noch das Problem
Wie gesagt das was ich vorhin gemeint habe
Dass die Leute das alles schon so mit einer gewissen Intention lesen
Leute die überall was was was linkes verwerfliches erkennen wollen finden das
Jede die alle Leute die überall irgendwie was weiß ich nazisachen finden wollen finden das auch
Alle die überall was sexistisches finden wollen finden das auch
Und so sind sie eigentlich schon den ganzen Tag allesamt sich am aufregen
Außer sie sollten sich mal
Sie sollten sich mal wirklich so ein bisschen am Dalai Lama orientieren
Und ich sage jetzt mal was abstraktes sollten alle mal versuchen dass die Welt zu einem besseren Platz wird
Wo man miteinander auskommt
Und da sind wir ja gerade in die entgegengesetzte Richtung
Wir kommen nicht besser miteinander aus
Weder international noch intern
Aber es ist mittlerweile schon so dass du wegen solchen Themen so richtig Reben in Familien hast
Und das sagt halt ja
LinkedIn richtig pock
Ja LinkedIn richtig
Richtig wollen wir Premium antreten
Ich bin mal gespannt wann ich gebannt werde für
Klarnamenpflicht nicht eingehalten
Wobei woher wollen ihr wissen vielleicht ihr wisst doch gar nicht wie ich heiße
Vielleicht heiße ich ja wirklich so
Was meint ihr wie ich auf Q-Chat gekommen bin vielleicht liegt es daran weil ich Kutter chatte heiß
Kutter chatte heiße ich
Kutter chatte
Kann doch sein
Das ist richtig Matze komplett richtig
Vor 10 Jahren war das noch nicht so wild ja
Da hat mit Sicherheit mit Sicherheit
Dass auf der einen Seite Social Media Sachen was miteinander beigetragen
Aber auch die
Wie soll ich sagen so
Extremisierung ist jetzt ein doofes Wort für so die die Verhärtung der fronten so
Zwischen allen lagern
Weil man nicht mehr so den Austausch miteinander gesucht hat
Letztendlich die Welt funktioniert ja Polarisierung genau
Das kommt halt noch dazu und Social Media
Aber wenn man sich mal so die Geschichte anguckt auch die Geschichte der Menschheit
Wird man feststellen dass das
Nie wirklich gut funktioniert hat
Wir sind eigentlich nur
Nur dort wo wir jetzt sind
Erstens weil wir Kompromisse schließen konnten
Und das wichtigste weil wir miteinander geredet haben
Uns gibt es heute gar nicht wenn wir nicht miteinander geredet hätten
Hätte hätte das eine
Lager nicht mit dem anderen gesprochen
Aber das eine etwas erfunden was das andere braucht
Dann wären die unabhängig voneinander ausgestorben
Uns gibt es nur weil wir weil wir reden
Jetzt so doof es klingt die Menschheit gibt es nicht mehr könnten sie nicht miteinander sprechen
Lustigerweise hat gerade
Dass man jetzt die Möglichkeit hat
Mit so vielen Leuten zu sprechen wie noch nie zuvor
Irrsinnigerweise dazu geführt
Dass man weniger miteinander spricht man spricht mehr miteinander
Aber man man man sagt weniger oder tauscht weniger aus oder
Übermittelt ums mit IT mäßig zu sagen
Übermittelt weniger Informationen als früher
Beziehungsweise vielleicht übermittel mehr Informationen zumindest
Das Gegenüber bei dem kommen keine Informationen mehr an
Obwohl man so viel so viel so einfach heute sagen kann über Social Media wie eigentlich nie zuvor
Aber es ist Fakt Leute wir wären ausgestorben hätten wir nicht
Miteinander geredet Packet loss genau
Wir wären ausgestorben
Eines der großen Vorteile was was wir als Menschen haben ist
Dass wir erstens
Ein recht gut funktionierendes Gehirn haben
Und gelernt haben zu sprechen
Das mit dem Gehirn weiß ich kommt bei vielen nicht so an
Aber wir können miteinander reden
Das ist eigentlich eines der wichtigsten Sachen
Wir können Informationen miteinander austauschen
Sprich wir können um es eigentlich um es eigentlich ein bisschen philosophisch
Wir können Gedanken austauschen miteinander
Das ist eigentlich das warum die Menschheit überhaupt überlebt hat
Weil wir Gedanken miteinander austauschen können
Der eine hat sich irgendwas cleveres gedacht und konnte es dem anderen erzählen
Und der hat es in seinem Gehirn wieder zu einem Gedanke umgewandelt
Und
Sonst gäbe es uns nicht mehr
Sonst sollten sich vielleicht alle Leute mal wieder im klaren sein
Dass so Kommunikation miteinander eigentlich
Eines der wichtigsten Sachen ist was die Menschheit kann
Oder warum es uns überhaupt gibt oder warum wir uns durchgesetzt haben hier auf dem Planet
Und keine
Keine Ahnung
Oktopus oder so
Gibt es ja auch Theorien zu
Wenn es die Menschen nicht gewesen wären wären es wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Timpenfische gewesen oder so
Hab ich mal irgendwo was zugelesen
Kein Witz ist jetzt echt kein Witz
Geht es wirklich Theorien zu
Dass wenn es die Menschen nicht geworden wären wären es wahrscheinlich Timpenfische
Hätten es eventuell Timpenfische werden können
Weil Timpenfische haben Big Brain
Im Verhältnis zum Rest
Oder Echsenmenschen ja
Aber guckt euch mal an das Hirn zu größten Verhältnissen bei so einem Dinosaurier
Das hat nicht gut funktioniert
Tja naja jetzt gut jetzt sind wir ein bisschen vom Thema abgekommen
Hat jetzt ja auch keinen Sinn da jetzt irgendwie noch irgendwie aufs Knie gebrauchen was zu machen
Ja ich
Habe ich dir jetzt erstmal ein bisschen drüber ausgelassen.
Aber ich finde es hier auf Twitch, insofern bei mir im Chat auch ganz angenehm, dass wir
keine Leute haben, die gleich instant rumschreien, wenn man mal was sagt, was man vielleicht
auch falsch verstehen kann.
Ich, also, ich meine, bei mir kriegt doch echt jeder, jeder sein Fett weg, oder?
Also, ich habe schon so ziemlich über alles und jeden, jegliche Gruppierung irgendwie
blöde Sprüche gemacht.
Und ich nehme mich ja noch nicht mal aus, ich mache so viele doofe Sprüche darüber, dass
ich zu fett bin.
Also, das ist wahrscheinlich mein meistgeprachter Witz von allen, ja.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was Hans Entertainment macht.
Ich wüsste gar nicht, wer Hans Entertainment ist, hätte ich nicht einen Kollegen auf der
Arbeit, der mir immer die neuesten Facebook News berichtet.
Ja, Leute, aber das dazu passt gar nicht, ne, da ich letztes Jahr auch noch abgenommen
habe und bis jetzt nicht wieder zugenommen habe.
Aber ich habe auch nur abgenommen, weil ich krank war, das habe ich euch ja erzählt.
Aber dafür recht ordentlich, zumindest in der kurzen Zeit.
Was?
What?
Also, wenn es zwei Leute gibt, die sich absolut nicht ähnlich sehen, dann, dann Hans Entertainment
und der Friseur Echt, wie gesagt, ich gucke den nicht, ich
habe keine Ahnung.
Übrigens, soll ich euch mal was erfreuliches zeigen?
Zeig euch mal was erfreuliches, guckt mal, in letzter Zeit geht es hier echt ganz gut
auf Twitch.
Ich meine, das sind keine Excusi-Zahlen oder so, aber da wäre ich damit auch nie hinkommen,
aber das ist schon nice, oder?
Ich mache ja nur wirklich echt krasses Nischenzeug.
Ich meine, wir machen eine merkwürdige Mischung aus ein bisschen Gaming, Technikgebastel,
sinnloses Gelaber, ab und zu mal in China was einkaufen, Linux-Kram, Server-Kram, Gebastel-Kram,
also ganz, ganz komische Sache, aber ich glaube, das ist auch der Grund, warum so viele Leute
am Start sind, weil das macht sonst irgendwie keiner.
Unentscheidend, unentscheidend gefällt es den Leuten ja auch hier, weil nur hier haben
wir ja den, das wissen wir ja, und nur hier gibt es EQ-Punkte für Summ, und wir haben
sogar Cobol programmiert, ja, nee, es ist schon vor Cobol, guckt mal, Monthly Gained
Followers, ab November, so ab wo ich jetzt richtig viel wieder gestritten habe, geht's
hoch, können wir hochrechnen, weil wir bei 5 Millionen im Monat sind.
Oh, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, das Bau, das guckt man nicht.
Ach nee, das hast du gar nicht geschrieben, ich hab, ihr habt beide grüne Benutzernahme,
ich hab das nur aus dem Augenwinkel gesehen, so, und jetzt wisst ihr was, ich hab noch mal
alles cooles zeigen muss, guckt mal hier, so sah das, Weekly Subscriber, also ich mach
so jede zweite Woche tausend Subs ungefähr, ich hab jetzt die letzten, den letzten Monat
über 2000, 2000 Subscriber gemacht auf YouTube wieder, also das ist natürlich nicht viel
im Vergleich zu dem, was ich früher gemacht hab, ja, aber früher hab ich auch noch Videos
hochgeladen, ich hab jetzt ja mehr oder weniger 6 Monate immer mal mit ein paar, mit ein bisschen
kurzen Etappen zwischen, ich hab ja quasi 6 Jahre, nicht Monate, 6 Jahre kaum was hochgeladen,
also was ich die letzten 6 Jahre hochgeladen hab, ist das, was ich sonst in einem Jahr
hochgeladen hab früher, aber kaum hab ich wieder angefangen hochzuladen und mir auch
immer ein bisschen Gedanken, um den Content zu machen, gehts wieder hoch, das POG, halbe
Million Aufrufe, 2K Abos, so, das heißt, wenn ich jetzt weitermache, dann schaff ich's
bis Ende des Jahres eventuell auf 300.000, das ist ja das, was ich schon, was ich mir
schon lange mal vorgenommen hab, aber nie angefangen, nie angegangen bin, ja, Ai Ryoku,
Dankeschön für den Prime Sub, AiQ++, Big Brain, dann schaff ich vielleicht, wenn ich
so weitermache, bis Ende des Jahres wirklich die 300K und das war natürlich wahnsinnig
nice, hab ich, ja, hab ich, hab ich, Schock Ops Gaming, habe ich und seitdem ich das mache,
hab ich mir auch einen Steuerberater gesucht, dann bin ich echt froh, dass ich einen Steuerberater
hab, weil ich krieg Anfälle, wenn ich das selbst machen müsste, ja und bei 1M Abos
Fails Reveal hab ich ja schon gesagt, aber 1M Abos werd ich in dem Tempo nicht mehr
schaffen, aber eins ist auf YouTube gewiss, dass man das eigentlich nicht weiß, weil bezahlt
sich der Steuerberater selbst, kommt aufs Jahr an, meistens schon, aber nicht immer.
Ja, und es ist ja auf YouTube so, dass das auch mal ganz schnell gehen kann, wenn ich
jetzt wirklich irgendwie eine Content Sache treffe, wo auf einmal irgendwie Gordon die
Welt sagt, boah, ist das geil, das wollt ihr schon immer sehen, das weißt ihr auf YouTube
vorher oftmals gar nicht, dann geht das auch ganz schnell, ja, aber wie gesagt, ich rechne
jetzt erstmal mit diesem Tempo ungefähr weiter und wenn ich irgendwie mal die 300.000 knacke,
das wär echt nice, also da, das ist ja so ne Sache, die hätt ich gerne noch geschafft
auf YouTube, was nicht heißt, dass ich dann aufhör oder so, aber, ähm, Reaction Content,
aber 300.000 ist wirklich so ein rundes Ding, das hätt ich gerne, ja gut, nee, ich hab's
nicht klug gemacht, überhaupt nicht, hätt ich das klug gemacht, dann hätt ich schon
die letzten sechs Jahre Videos gemacht und es gab die letzten sechs Jahre über so viele
Hypes, Gaming technisch, wo ich zumindest ein bisschen hätte mitmachen können und sei
es so, dass ich das gemacht hätte, was, was ich quasi schon immer gerne gemacht hab,
meinen Senf dazu abgeben, ja, hätt ich meinen Senf zu Puppe abgegeben, als Puppe im Hype
war, hätt ich meinen Senf dazu abgegeben, als Fortnite im Hype war, als was auch immer,
das wär übelst abgegangen, ja, aber ich hatte die letzten sechs Jahre irgendwie kein Bock,
ich kann's, ich kann's schlecht beschreiben, woran das gelegen hat und ich kann's auch
schlecht beschreiben, warum ich jetzt wieder Bock hab, also deswegen so viel, so viel zum
Thema, hab ich klug gemacht, nee, hab ich nicht, überhaupt nicht, ich mein, wirkt
jetzt so wie der krasse Masterplan, aber ist es nicht, nee, und jetzt hab ich mir halt
folgendes überlegt, weil ich hab ja schon mal ab und zu so Aktivitätsphasen gehabt,
aber die gingen nicht lang, dass ich jetzt, wie gesagt, ich werd nicht versuchen quasi,
dass ich in einem gewissen Abstand Videos machen muss, früher hab ich dann gesagt, Max,
mach mal alle zwei Tage was, dass du ein bisschen was im Voraus hast und solche Sachen, da hatt
ich immer ganz schnell keinen Bock drauf, ich hab mir jetzt so gesagt, über den Daumen
gepeilt, so keine Ahnung, so alle vier Tage, alle vier, fünf Tage, aber so mindestens
ein Video mal in der Woche, das glaub ich ganz nice und dementsprechend kann ich dann
auch mir wirklich längere Zeit Gedanken drüber machen, was ich für einen Content bring und
die Mischung ist ja auch recht einzigartig, muss man sagen, ich mein, woanders kriegt man
irgendwelchen Oldschool Battlefield Shit, den anscheinend immer noch so viele Leute
interessiert, irgendwelche IT-Bastlgelaber, Stellenanzeigen, lustige Mache und sonstige
Sachen in einem Paket und witzigerweise auch noch, dass das zum größten Teil die Leute
trifft, die das alles, wie du hier schreibst, die das dann auch noch alles interessiert,
weil ich seh die gleichen Leute immer unter den Videos, ich seh die gleichen Leute unter
dem Video, wo ich mich darüber auskotze, dass das Internet in Deutschland so schlecht
ist, unter dem Video, wo ich mich über IT-Stellenanzeigen lustig mach oder unter dem Video, wo ich irgendwelche
neuen Battlefield 3 Sachen zeige von Spiel, was 10 Jahre alt ist, also es scheinen ja
auch irgendwie nur die gleichen zu interessieren, ja, was mit Willi Peets Cast ist, weiß ich
wirklich nicht, ja, aber ich hab mir auch schon überlegt, ich kenn ja noch den ein
oder anderen, ja, und ich denke mal, dass da wahrscheinlich auch mit mir ein paar Videos
aufnehmen würden, aber ich muss halt sagen, es bringt halt auch nix, wenn man, also bringt
vielleicht schon Zuschauer, aber ich denk mal so für die Atmosphäre auf dem Channel
ist es nicht so gut, wenn man das mit gar so Themen fremden Leuten, weiß ich nicht, macht,
ja, und auf der anderen Seite, weiß ich nicht, also es muss ja auch allen beiden irgendwie
was bringen, zumal ihr kennt mich, ich mag eigentlich keine anderen Leute, bis auf ein
paar Ausnahmen und den Chat natürlich, da mach ich lieber mein Zeug, was auch den Vorteil
hat, dass ich mich mit YouTube Deutschland nicht auseinandersetzen muss, mir geht YouTube
Deutschland so am Arsch vorbei und mir hätte auch dieses Streaming Drama der letzten Tage
nicht mehr am Arsch vorbei gehen können, ja, ich fand die ursprüngliche Sache kacke,
an dem sich das ganze entzündet hat da, ja, zu so einer Aussage, das fand ich nicht toll,
was da gelaufen ist, aber was da wieder für einen riesen Aufrist rumgemacht wurde, war
auch nicht normal, ja, exzellent, ja, viele, diese Stellenanzeige Review Video haben auch
so viele gesehen und auch viele neue, so, und jetzt mal das zu beantworten, was hier
Shoggawks Gaming gefragt hat, oh, das kann ich dir nicht sagen, Glück haben, ich glaube,
diese Nischen gibt es nicht, ich glaube, es gibt keine Nische, dass man den Leuten Home
Network und Freenas quasi als Service verkaufen kann, ich glaube, da gibt es keine wirkliche
Nische für die Leute, die da ein bisschen größeres Setup geplant haben, die sind selber
recht fit und machen das und die anderen kriegen das quasi beim Hausbauen empfohlen
und gemacht und da kommst du gar nicht rein, ich glaube, da gibt es keine Nische für,
aber zu der anderen Frage, du hattest vorher doch noch irgendwas mit, wo es auf jeden Fall
eine Nische gibt, ist immer noch lokal, ja, wenn du zum Beispiel, wenn der Nachbar Handwerker
ist, wenn du für den irgendwelche Webservice Sachen machst, das ist sicherlich immer
noch irgendwas, was geht, weil die halt gar keinen Plan haben und auch nie jemand fragen
würden, aber wenn du dem sagst, hier soll ich dir was machen, so nach dem Motto 500 Euro
erstmal initial und dann monatlich ein bisschen was für Hosting und Service, könnte man bestimmt
machen, hätte ich aber keinen Bock drauf, achja, sag ich gleich was zu, hätte ich aber
echt keinen Bock drauf und ansonsten, IT Service ist keine Ahnung, was man da machen
könnte, du brauchst Big Brain Stonks Startup Idee, auf geht's, vorherige Frage, in wie
weit musst du dich da mit deinem Arbeitgeber absprechen, meines Wissens nach, ich kann
jetzt bloß sagen, da wo ich mich da drüber informiert hab, meines Wissens nach, musst
du das anmelden bei deinem Arbeitgeber, aber, da hab ich zum fünften Mal das Ding gestartet,
aber dein Arbeitgeber darf da gar nichts gegen sagen, es sei denn, es sprechen irgendwelche
wichtigen betrieblichen Gründe bei deinem Arbeitgeber dagegen, zum Beispiel du machst
ihm direkt Konkurrenz oder sowas, das ist was anderes, aber wenn dein Arbeitgeber sagt
nein, das geht jetzt gerade nicht, weil sagen wir, du bist der einzige in dem Bereich, der
was kann und deswegen wird sein Betrieb pleite gehen, wenn du nur noch die Hälfte arbeitest,
das kann der Arbeitgeber sagen, aber wenn der sowas sagt, muss der auch gleichzeitig Abhilfe
schaffen, also der kann sich da mit nicht für immer rausreden, ich glaube das einzige,
wo ich den Arbeitgeber mit rausreden kann, ist wenn du ihm direkt Konkurrenz machst,
also im Prinzip kann dein Arbeitgeber dir das auch gar nicht verbieten, aber du musst
ihm sagen, du musst ihm sagen, am besten schriftlich und dir unterschreiben lassen,
Smart Tactics kennst du anscheinend aus, naja, ja gut, ich ja auch, bei mir war es ein großer
Akt, bei mir war es ein großer Akt, aber das lag an meinem alten Chef, der es verkackt
hat.
Ich bin zu meinem damaligen Teamleiter und habe gesagt, ich will weniger arbeiten, das
war ja eh witzig, ich habe gesagt, hier, wir müssen mal kurz hier vorgezogen das Mitarbeitergespräch
machen, ich muss was mit dir besprechen und da meint er dann auch schon so, ah Max, ist
es soweit, möchtest du mehr Verantwortung übernehmen, so nach dem Motto, haben unsere
jahrelange Gelaber für Karrieremöglichkeiten endlich gefruchtet, wie sieht es aus, Projektleitung
sonst was, und ich habe gesagt, nee, nee, deswegen frage ich dich nicht, ich will weniger
arbeiten.
Da hat er erstmal blöd geguckt, ich habe gesagt, ich will weniger arbeiten, weißt du, der weiß
das, weißt du, ich mache immer noch YouTube Sachen und im Internet so Krams nebenbei
und das läuft eigentlich auch ganz gut, ich brauche da jetzt ein bisschen mehr Zeit für,
hat er sofort verstanden, okay, gehe ich mal zu unserem, ich sag mal, Abteilungsleiter
oder so war das damals und der Abteilungsleiter ist dann hoch zu unserem Geschäfts-Dings-Vertreter-Typ
gegangen, also der, der den Kram letztendlich auch unterschreiben muss und das Problem war
nur, dass mein damaliger Abteilungsleiter, der wollte, der war eh komisch der Typ, der
war der Meinung, das ist was, was ich auch überhaupt nicht abkann, der war der Meinung,
er hat so einen Erziehungsauftrag, so einen Erziehungsauftrag auch bei Leuten, die 30
plus sind, ganz komischer Kerl und da hat er das unserem Geschäftsführer, nenne ich
ihn jetzt mal, ist er nicht, aber so in der Richtung, total mies verkauft mit, dass ich
Teilzeit arbeiten will, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie er das ihm verkauft hat, ich vermute mal,
dass es in die Richtung ging, so nach dem Motto, ey ich hab da einen, der will weniger
arbeiten, das machen wir doch nicht, oder, und dann hat dann unser Abteilungsober, Obermann
gesagt, ne ne, das machen wir nicht, so in der Richtung stelle ich mir das vor, dass
das so gelaufen ist, weil hätte er ihm das normal erzählt, hätte der da definitiv nichts
gegen gesagt, weil er genau gewusst hätte, er kann da nichts gegen sagen und was habe
ich dann gemacht, mir ist nichts anderes übrig geblieben, bevor ich da jetzt selbst hoch
gehe und ich nicht weiß, was gelaufen ist, und im Zweifelsfall es dann auch heißt, ne
geht nicht und dann irgendwie, was auch immer noch für Sachen sich ausgedacht werden, bin
ich damals zum Betriebsrat gegangen und hab ihm das erzählt, die haben auch gemeint,
hä ne, ergibt doch überhaupt keinen Sinn, und dann sind die dorthin und dann hat er,
dann hat unser Geschäftsführer, der stellt, ich frag mich keine Ahnung, was das überhaupt
genau für einer ist, sofort gesagt, ne ne, das ist gar kein Problem, ging dann easy und
er hat ihn dann auch so gesagt, dass das so nie bei ihm angefragt wurde, also was heißt,
mein alter Chef hat maßlos verkackt und ich denke sogar absichtlich, so, deswegen hat
es bei mir lange gedauert, bis das funktioniert hat, aber dagegen sagen konnte auch keiner
was, das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass das funktioniert, da würde ich nichts hosten,
ganz ehrlich, im Server Rack bei einem daheim, würde ich nichts hosten, bring ab dem ersten
zweiten Althieler in der Brauerei Pog, ernsthaft, wupp Pog, Leute, mehr kann man dazu nicht
sagen, wupp Pog, ja, wie gesagt, bei mir war es auch kein Problem, nachdem es mal richtig
angekommen ist, so, und dann gab es irgendwie noch eine andere Frage, hab ich grad nicht
gesehen, also, kannst du kurz für einen Noob erklären, ist der Chat aus, weil es keiner
was schreibt, was ist denn auf einmal los, ihr seid so ruhig, ah ja, cbh, Twitch Prime,
Dankeschön, für die Subscription, kannst du kurz für Noobs erklären, warum man, warum
genau man Server-seitige Virtualisierung betreibt, ja, umgedrehte Frage, warum betreibt man denn
Software, Desktop-seitige Virtualisierung, das ist im Prinzip der gleiche Grund, warum
man Server-seitige Virtualisierung betreibt, zumindest teilweise, wupps, hab ich ja schon
gesehen, cbh, danke für den Sub, also, der hauptsächliche Grund, es gibt, es stimmt
nicht ganz, was ich gesagt hab, es gibt mehrere Gründe, warum man Server-seitige Virtualisierung
betreibt, das erste ist, weil man vielleicht Software laufen lassen hat, die auf dem eigentlichen
System nicht mehr funktioniert, ja, zum Beispiel, wir haben noch, ich kann das jetzt mal als
Beispiel nehmen, wir haben noch ein ganz, ganz altes Datenbank-System, was manchmal
unser Verkauf braucht, oder Einkauf braucht, da stehen irgendwelche Inventarsachen drinne
oder so, und das läuft noch mit einer uralten unsupporteten Oracle-Version auf einem Redhead
5, was selbst sich als Redhead 4 ausgibt, dass es noch funktioniert, also ihr könnt
euch jetzt überlegen, wie alt das ist, so, und das funktioniert auf aktueller Hardware,
aktueller Betriebssysteme, geht nicht mehr, ja, so, und da ist das natürlich eine gute
Sache, das Ganze zu virtualisieren, kann man sich überlegen, vielleicht packt man es auch
in einen Container, aber das Ganze voll zu virtualisieren ist das einfachste, das voll
virtualisiert, nennt meinetwegen sogar einen Redhead 4 drauf und gib ihm und bis in aller
Ewigkeit kannst du es laufen lassen, so, das ist das erste, und das zweite ist, und
wahrscheinlich eines der häufigsten Sachen, warum man Server-Virtualisierung macht, ist,
du kannst damit ganz gut Ressourcen besser, wie soll man sagen, besser managen, ja, und
skalieren, also sprich, du kannst zum Beispiel, wenn du eine fette Hardware hast mit, was
weiß ich, 48 CPU-Kernen, 2TB RAM und haste nicht gesehen, die wirst du recht schwierig
ausgelastet bekommen mit einer Anwendung oder mit einem Anwendungszweck, allerdings hast
du vielleicht Bedarf für so viel Rechenleistung, allerdings nicht für einen Anwendungszweck,
sondern vielleicht für 30 verschiedene Anwendungszwecke, also virtualisierst du die ganzen Sachen,
klatschst sie auf die fette Hardware drauf, haste im Endeffekt Hardware gespart, weil
du weniger brauchst und hast trotzdem die Leistung, die du benötigst und gleichermaßen
ist es auch noch viel einfacher, die Sachen hoch verfügbar zu machen, das bringt zum
Beispiel VM-Ware, bringt da schon jede Menge Sachen mit, dass du VMs quasi verschieben
kannst automatisch, wenn was kaputt geht und sowas, du musst dich dann quasi betriebssystemseitig
und anwendungsseitig oftmals weniger um Hochverfügbarkeitssachen kümmern und ein aktuell sehr wichtiger
Punkt, der auch für Virtualisierung und vor allem für Container spricht, ist, man kann
das einfacher skalieren, also sprich, wenn du 5 Server hast für eine Web-Anwendung und
abends kommt auf einmal dein Shop in den Nachrichten und alle gehen auf deinen Shop drauf oder auf
dein Webservice drauf, dann musst du erstmal normalerweise 10 Server einbauen gehen im
Rechenzentrum, was du nachts um 23 Uhr wahrscheinlich nicht machst, aber hast du das virtualisiert
und einen ordentlich großen Hardwarepool, kannst du ohne Probleme auch komplett automatisch
anstatt 5 VMs 30 VMs starten und es geht recht easy, hat es nicht, hat es nicht, hat es nicht,
es hat viel weniger Overhead als man eigentlich denkt, also generell Containerisierung hat
eigentlich, ich will jetzt nicht sagen gar kein, aber im Prinzip gar kein Overhead,
Container ist ja keine Virtualisierung im eigentlichen Sinne, wie gesagt, Container
heißt es eigentlich komplett falsch, das wirkt so als hätte es irgendwas mit Virtualisierung
zu tun oder sonst was, denn im Container gestarteter Prozess ist exakt das gleiche
wie nicht im Container gestarteter Prozess, außer dass Kernel mäßig ein paar Sachen
mehr aktiv sind, das macht überhaupt keinen Unterschied, also ob du den Java im Container
startest oder den Java im Host startest, macht unerm Strich keinen Unterschied, das ist der
gleiche Kernel in dem das läuft, dementsprechend kannst du auch da keine Kernelmodule verwenden,
die im Host Kernel nicht gehen und sowas, ja genau, dementsprechend es ist schlicht
nachgreifend ein stinknormaler Prozess auf deinem Host, nur dass noch ein bisschen mehr
Sandboxing vielleicht dazwischen ist.
So, und das nächste ist, das ist so viel zum Thema Container, da ist es relativ schnell
abgehakt, dass das eigentlich keinen wirklichen Overhead hat oder keinen nennenswerten, also
wirklich nix eigentlich, nix, ja, so, bei Virtualisierung sieht es ein bisschen anders
aus, aber auch Virtualisierung hat kaum Overhead, CPU mäßig, wo Virtualisierung Overhead hat
ist ein bisschen Ram-Auslastung, aber gar nicht so sehr, bisschen Ram-Auslastung, weil
du hast ja quasi komplett eigenes Betriebssystem nochmal laufen, Ram-Auslastung ein bisschen,
aber hauptsächlich halt insgesamt Speicherverbrauch, aber CPU ist virtualisiert auch so gut wie
kein Overhead, also das ist tatsächlich weniger als man denkt, also die Vorteile überwiegen
da ganz eindeutig, ja ich weiß, deswegen ich gehe auch gleich auf, ja genau, ja, genau,
so und das ganze wird nochmal doppelt interessant, wenn die 48 CPU Kerne und 2TB RAM Kiste nicht
bei dir im Rechenzentrum steht und auch nicht beim Cloud-Anbieter steht, sondern wenn du
das den Cloud-Anbieter managen lässt, also sprich, du kaufst dir dann keinen Server
bei Hetzner mit 48 Kern und 2TB RAM und machst das gleiche nur woanders, sondern du kaufst
ja gar keine Hardware im eigentlichen Sinne mehr, sondern machst die Ressourcen on Demand
und da wird es halt gerade aktuell interessant, wenn es um die ganze Cloud-Geschichte geht
und warum da so viele Schafe drauf sind, aber man muss sagen, das macht es nicht unbedingt
billiger, also dass die, dass die Sachen outgesourced in die Cloud viel billiger sind, halte ich
für Gerücht, das mag in manchen Fällen so sein, zum größten Teil eher nicht, zumindest
nicht in den direkten, direkten Kosten, wo es eventuell sich trotzdem lohnen könnte,
ist wenn man alles mit einberechnet, ja, zum Beispiel, wenn du wirklich, sagen wir mal,
du bist jetzt kein allzu, allzu, ähm, allzu großer Laden und du kannst wirklich dein
komplettes Rechenzentrum abschalten, weil du alles irgendwie bei dem Cloud-Anbieter
betreibst, das hat einen Vorteil, du brauchst, du brauchst kein Rechenzentrum mehr, du brauchst,
von Strom und Gedöns reden wir mal gar nicht, du brauchst aber auch kein Personal mehr,
was sich um das Rechenzentrum kümmert und sonstige Geschichten, also du kannst da an
anderen Stellen auch was einsparen, also im Gesamten, im Gesamten kann das durchaus sein,
dass es billiger ist, aber ich bezweifle es trotzdem, dass es billiger ist, ähm, warum
das aktuell so viele Leute machen, ist glaube ich das, warum auch so viele Leute Service-Verträge
abschließen, äh, für, für ruhiger schlafen können. Ja, die sagen halt, okay, ähm, wenn
wir uns selber nicht, um alles was wir uns nicht selber kümmern müssen, ist gut für uns.
Das, ich glaube, das zusammengefasst ist so der, der Grundgedanke dahinter. Ja, und das,
deswegen, das mit dem Shop ist ein gut, ist ein gutes Beispiel, ja. Deswegen ist es auch
bescheuert zu sagen, wir haben einen Service-Offline bei sich im Rechenzentrum oder On-Premise,
wie man das heutzutage so cool nennt, Offline oder beziehungsweise im Rechenzentrum bei
sich oder, äh, Rackspaces nennt man nicht mal so, man nennt das On-Premise, weil die
coolen Leute es halt On-Premise nennen. Warum auch immer, weil On-Premise jetzt das geilste
neue Wort dafür ist, aber im Prinzip das, was man die letzten 40 Jahre gemacht hat, ist
On-Premise. Ja, das ist auch genau, man hat eine gute Übersicht, wer was verbraucht in
der Cloud, ja, das kommt auch noch dazu. Ähm, fuck, was wollte ich jetzt sagen? Lul, Brainlag,
keine Ahnung. Ja, ah ja, genau, da hab ich gar nicht an richtig. Ähm, ja, das weiß,
da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern, aber ich weiß nicht mehr, warum ich das gesagt hab.
Ähm, das stimmt, wo sich, wo sich die ganze Sache auch richtig lohnt, ist, wenn du Power
brauchst, aber nicht oft. Ich hab zum Beispiel ein Projekt mit einem Kollegen gemacht, ist
grad nicht so aktiv, aber dafür weiß ich, dafür hab ich's gebraucht. Ich hab einmal
im Monat 96 Gigabyte RAM und 24 CPU Kerne gebraucht. Könnten wir auch mal machen. Einmal
im Monat für zwei Stunden. So. Ich hab mir einfach ne Kiste gemietet, hab das gemacht,
was ich gemacht, machen musste, hab dann vier Euro bezahlt oder so am Ende und die Kiste
war wieder weg. Dafür ist es natürlich auch extrem praktisch.
Ach ja, genau, jetzt weiß ich, was ich sagen wollte, genau, diese ganze On-Premise-Geschichte,
also, dass, ähm, es ja keinen Sinn hat, wenn man die Sache jetzt oft bei sich gehorstet
hat im Rechenzentrum und man sagt, man geht in die Cloud und man mietet sich bei Azure
ne VM mit zwei Terabyte und 96, äh, und, äh, 48 CPU Kerne und macht in der Azure VM exakt
das Gleiche wie auf seiner Hardware lokal. Das ist die, die easy Variante, die ergibt
aber nur teilweise Sinn. Weil da hat man eigentlich das Schlechte aus beiden Welten,
wenn man mal ehrlich ist. Das heißt, man muss gucken, dass seine Software sich dafür
auch eignet und man muss sich da ein bisschen Gedanken drum machen.
Hä, was meinste? Ach so, ähm, OpenStreetMaps-Rooting-Informationen-Pre-Processed, dass man Routen errechnen
konnte. Das braucht, für ganz Europa braucht das RAM, SFAC und CPU und ordentlich Rechenleistung.
Ja, also einfach nur die Sachen in der Cloud vor allem schieben ist jetzt auch nicht Sinn
und Zweck der Übung. Ähm, die eigentlich sinnvolle Sache ist dann, dass man seine Anwendung
so programmiert, dass man das eben mit, ähm, von Azure zur Verfügung gestellt, mit Google,
mit was auch immer, zur Verfügung gestellten Cloud-Services laufen lassen kann, weil dann
muss man sich auch nicht mehr um den klassischen Server kümmern. Weil ansonsten hast du im
Prinzip das Schlechte aus zwei Welten. Du hast noch einen Cloud-Anbieter am Start, du bist
genauso wenig hoch verfügbar wie sonst, ja, eine Azure-VM ist eine Azure-VM. Es macht
keinen Unterschied, ob es eine Azure-VM ist oder eine VM bei dir. Vielleicht ein bisschen,
aber im Prinzip ist es eine VM. Du musst dich da auch um alles selbst kümmern, du
musst dich um das Betriebssystem selbst kümmern, du brauchst Leute, die das administrieren
und alles. Also eine VM in Azure ist eigentlich das Schlechteste aus beiden Welten. Viel besser
ist, man baut seine Anwendung so, dass man sie eben mit den Services laufen lassen kann,
die beispielsweise Azure oder Google oder wer auch immer zur Verfügung stellt. Ja, das
heißt, dass man irgendwie Cosmos DB verwendet oder Fauna DB oder was auch immer. Oder was
ist sonst noch angesagt? Fire DB und Firestorm, alle möglichen Sachen. Muss man sich halt
gucken, dass man da sich einen sinnvollen, ich sag mal so einen Tech-Stack raussucht,
so dass man eben keine VM braucht. Natürlich kann das durchaus sinnvoll sein, aber halt
ein bisschen abgespeckt. Dass man nicht alles da drauf laufen lässt, sondern halt nur noch
da, wo es dann Sinn macht. Es muss nicht alles wild skalieren. Ja, wenn man einmal im Monat
ein E-Mail-Newsletter verschickt, das kann durchaus auf einer VM laufen, wenn man da
Custom-Sachen braucht. Aber vielleicht das Login für den Shop, wo ab und zu dann mal
30.000 draufgehen, manchmal auch nur 500, das wäre dann vielleicht doch nicht so sinnvoll.
Ja, nicht unbedingt. Ich glaube, ich würde da ein bisschen unterschiedliche Sachen draus
verstehen. Also wenn ich was auslage und outsource, dann ist es wirklich so, dass ich nur mir
den Service komplett dort kaufe. Also sprich, sagen wir mal so, ich brauche ein Seminar-Buchungssystem,
ich kaufe mir bei einem Anbieter ein Seminar-Buchungssystem, das wird dort gehostet und dort betrieben
und ich benutze das als reiner Anwender. Wenn ich sagen, die Cloud-Package heißt das
für mich, das kann durchaus noch Software sein, die ich entwickelt habe und die ich
auch weiterentwickeln werde, aber ich kümmere mich nicht mal um die Infrastruktur, wo es
drauf läuft. Ich finde, das sind schon ein bisschen zwei unterschiedliche Geschichten.
Das ist nice. Das habe ich noch nie gemacht. Wollen wir das mal im Stream machen? Minikube
oder irgendwie ein bisschen Kubernetes auf Raspberry Pi? Ich habe ja mittlerweile, ich
habe noch ein paar Dreier, jetzt wieder ein Vierer. Können wir mal ausprobieren? Da
war Kubernetes-Cluster auf Raspberry Pi, das reibe ich schon mal auf. Aber ich sage euch
gleich, so raw Kubernetes bin ich auch nicht der Pro, aber dann lerne ich was. Wo wir gerade
dabei sind, hat doch jemand am Anfang gefragt, war der Windows-Sound bei dir? Ne. Ne, aber
der eben war vorher nicht bei mir. Der war wirklich nicht bei mir da eben. Also der ICQ-Sound
schon, aber der da vorne nicht. Das wollte ich jetzt sagen, siehst du, sidetracked.
Genau, wie gesagt, große Kubernetes kennen damit ich und wie gesagt, weil es vorher
jemand gefragt hat, ob ich mich nach der Ausbildung noch fortgebildet habe. Ja, immer. Sobald
du aufhörst, sich fortzubilden, sagst du. Ist so. Du hast schnell keinen Plan mehr. Und
es ist gar nicht wichtig, dass du es kannst. Es ist wichtig, dass du weißt, wo du gucken
musst. No Happy Meal for you. Dankeschön für 13 Monate Hyper-Subscription. Also du
musst wissen, was angesagt ist. Also du musst die ganzen Begriffe mal gehört haben, du
musst wissen, wonach du suchst. Du musst das nicht alles können. Keiner kann immer
den neuesten, hipsten Shit alles. Aber du musst wissen, was es ist. Ja, zum Beispiel
Dinox fragt mich nach Rancher. Ich weiß, was es ist. Ich habe sogar mal Rancher OS Login
gesehen, aber ich habe dazu keine Meinung, weil ich die benutzt habe. Aber ich könnte
nachgucken, ich weiß, was es ist, ich könnte nachgucken und ich könnte mir das innerhalb
von ein paar Tagen angucken, dass ich zumindest halbwegs benutzen könnte. Das ist das Wichtige,
deswegen, sobald du aufhörst, dich mit neuen Sachen zu beschäftigen, sagst du einfach
nach kurzer Zeit. Es ist so. Und deswegen bringt es auch nichts, IT-Sachen zu machen,
weil man keine Ahnung, weil es der Vater gemacht hat oder irgendwas. Man muss davon
schon überzeugt sein. Und auch nichts zu sagen, hey, ich mache das nur, weil ich Geld
verdienen will. Klar, im Prinzip, wir gehen alle arbeiten, um Geld zu verdienen. 99% mache
ich das, was ich jetzt mache, auch um Geld zu verdienen. Aber, was ich sagen will, prinzipiell
muss man sich schon für IT-Technik und Gebastel interessieren. Beispielsweise mein Micro-Controller
gedönnt, was ich daheim mache, interessiert mich. Bringt mir jetzt für die Arbeit direkt
nichts. Aber ich wette mit euch, irgendwann zahlt sich das noch aus, dass ich das mal
gemacht habe. Und sei es so, dass wir vielleicht mal eine C++-Anwendung haben, wo ich den Sourcecode
besser lesen kann oder was auch immer. Es bringt alles irgendwann mal was. Ja, da hast
du recht. So Leute, 5 Minuten höchstens noch. Der Azure-Trainer, den wir mal hatten, wir
hatten mal so einen Typ von Microsoft Partner, der bei uns so Azure-Schulungen gemacht hat.
Ich habe ja mittlerweile auch schon ein paar Azure-Schulungen gemacht, die teilweise echt
lustig waren, mit abgelaufener Windows-Lizenz und sowas in der Richtung. Und da hat er gemeint,
ja sie sind auch ganz toll mit Interop, mit anderen Clouds. Und da hat er gesagt, ja also
mit AWS und mit Google und sonst wie. Und da habe ich ihn gefragt, und wie sieht es mit
der Telekom Cloud aus? Das hat er gar nicht beantwortet, hat er einfach nur so gemacht.
Und da hat er gemeint, ich verstehe ihn bestimmt und ich habe gesagt, ja verstehe ich. Was machst
du aber, wenn du alle Cloud-Anbieter nutzen musst und nicht von dem Anbieter eigene
Produkte nutzen kannst? Hä? Na ich suche mir den Anbieter raus, der für mich passt. Oder
verstehe ich es jetzt nicht? Also im Allgemeinen, du hast selbst ein Software programmiert.
Und du willst selbst das programmieren, in irgendeine Web-Anwendung, nehmen wir jetzt
mal beispielsweise. Dann suchst du dir halt den Anwender raus, der das kann, was du brauchst.
Ja im Zweifelsfall, wenn du nicht weißt, was, nimm Netlify oder sowas. Ich meine mit Anbieter,
ne ne ne, ich meine kein fertiges Produkt von dem jeweiligen Anbieter, sondern eben die
Technologie, die der Anbieter anbietet. Ja, zum Beispiel eine gehostete Datenbank bei
denen. Also dass du nicht eine eigene VM installierst mit Postgres drauf, sondern dass die der
vielleicht eben SS-Service schon anbietet. Wenn ich Postgres benutzen will, suche ich
mir halt einen Anbieter, der das hat. Oder vielleicht nehme ich was ganz anderes.
Äh, neue PMD-Folie habe ich schon gesehen, aber Dankeschön nochmal.
Excellent. Ja, nicer, nicer Streamer, ich hab mir aber ziemlich alles ausgelassen.
Richtig! Deswegen muss es einem ja auch Bock machen!
Correct. Open Telekom Cloud, ja, Telekom Excellent Center haben wir ja vorhin gelernt. Es geht
darum, du hast gesagt, man nimmt am besten die Produkte vom Anbieter und nicht einfach
die VM. Genau. Aber es gibt Anfragen, die kannst du damit... Ja klar, wenn es aus irgendwelchen
Gründen nicht geht, dann musst du ne VM nehmen, ja klar. Ja, also wahrgenommen, dein Chef
sagt jetzt, du darfst das nicht mehr lokal betreiben, du musst das bei Azure betreiben,
aber deine Anwendung braucht partout, keine Ahnung, lokal installiertes MySQL, Emmer's
SQL und Red Hat 4 von Abhängigkeiten und was auch immer, dann musst du ne VM nehmen.
Jaja, da kommst du nicht drum rum. Aber vor allem, wenn du ne maintainte Anwendung hast
oder was, was du neu bastelst, dann würde ich halt gucken, dass man es nicht so macht,
dass man ein komplettes Betriebssystem oder VM irgendwo in der Cloud sich mietet, sondern
dass man die Anwendung so programmiert, dass die eben mit fertigen Cloud Services funktioniert,
dass du dich nicht mehr um den Müll kümmern musst. Hey Max, wir haben bei uns mehrere
VMs, da wollte ich mal fragen, ob es besser ist, die Mittel, die wir nutzen, auf mehrere
VMs zu splitten oder alles auf, das weiß ich nicht. Woher soll ich das denn wissen?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was es ist, was ihr macht, ist nachts kälter als draußen, keine
Ahnung. Nee, ernsthaft, da kann ich, so kann ich da wirklich nichts zu sagen. Zum Beispiel
nur, dass man mal sieht, wie unterschiedlich das sein kann. Es gibt Sachen, die lassen
dich super parallelisieren, wenn du allerdings in Battlefield 3, wenn es an Leash Server laufen
lassen willst, da brauchst du viel Single Core Performance. Also es ist komplett abhängig
von der Anwendung und was ihr machen wollt. Nee, da kann ich wirklich so nichts zu sagen.
Ja, da muss man auch ein bisschen aufpassen, so Microservices Rittes. Man muss nicht jeden
Scheiß in einem Container und als Microservice und sonst was machen, also man kann es ja
auch echt übertreiben. Wie gesagt, es gibt bestimmt Leute, die starten ihr Editor demnächst
in einem Docker-Container. LSS-Service oder sowas kommt irgendwann noch. Ich finde es
ist durchaus okay, wenn man eine Anwendung programmiert, dass man da auch die eine oder
andere Funktionalität Hardcoded einbaut, ohne 50 Services dafür ansprechen zu müssen,
dass es funktioniert. Das kann man schon machen. Das ist in Ordnung, weil man darf nichts vergessen.
Nichts ist besser als ein lokaler Funktionsaufruf. Performance Overhead geschwindigkeitsmäßig.
Muss man gucken, was man macht. Es bietet sich an, das zu benutzen, wenn es etwas ist,
was man nicht unbedingt selbst einbauen will oder selber machen will oder asynchron ausgeführt
werden muss oder so. Man muss es nicht übertreiben, das stimmt. Wieso sind momentan Komponenten
so teuer? Weil es wenig gibt und sich alle drauf stürzen. Ganz einfach. Ja, bei uns
ist das auch mittlerweile echt wir. Bei uns ist eine Mischung aus läuft lokal, läuft
in der Cloud und eigentlich blickt keiner mehr durch, was jetzt wie irgendwo ist. Das
ist bei uns echt ultra wirk gerade. Aber ich hab mir jetzt angewöhnt, ich ignoriere das
einfach. Also was man bei uns machen muss ist, immer wenn etwas Neues kommt, ich hoffe
mein Chef guckt jetzt nicht zu, immer wenn etwas Neues kommt, muss man bei uns einfach
erst mal einen Monat warten und ignorieren und wenn es nach einem Monat nicht weg ist,
dann ist es vielleicht doch interessant. Ansonsten kommt und geht gerade aktuell so viel, da blickt
keiner mehr durch. Und by the way, ich mag Jenkins. Ich weiß nicht, was es ist an Jenkins,
vor allem weil es auch noch eine Java Anwendung ist und ihr wisst ja, ich bin ja auch so großer
Java Fan. Ich mag Jenkins, kann nicht genau sagen, warum. Wahrscheinlich weil Jenkins
so ein richtig wildes, du kannst alles selbst machen, aber es ist halt vielleicht nicht
die beste Usability, aber du kannst halt alles selbst machen mit. Also Jenkins kannst du
wirklich jede noch so versaute Sache in Jenkins bauen, einfach weil du viele Customscripts
machen kannst. Vielleicht gefällt es mir deswegen. Also ich mag Jenkins, ich würde es vielleicht
nicht unbedingt jetzt in so einem super hippen Agile Project was auch immer machen, aber
so für mich privat daheim, wenn ich irgendwie nach einem Push was bilden will oder so, würde
ich einen Jenkins nehmen. Wobei ich da nicht so viele Sachen habe, das meiste ist easy
as fuck, da brauchst du keine großartigen Builds oder sonst was und das eine Projekt,
was ich hab auf GitHub, das mache ich mit GitHub Actions, inklusive Deployment. So Leute,
aber ich geh jetzt ins Bett, machts gut, wir sehen uns morgen oder so, bis denn, wir sehen
uns, CU. Brauchen wir Auto, Musik? War's gut, bis denn.
Untertitel im Auftrag des ZDF, 2020